things are getting a bit spicy up in
france over a hundred thousand people
were protesting in the streets
many of them were rioting a vaccination
center was
set on fire and several others were
vandalized because emmanuel macron has
introduced a law
that if you cannot prove you are
vaccinated
you will get up to six months in prison
if you run an establishment open to the
public and you do
not have if you are not checking people
if they're vaccinated
you will get up to a year in prison well
naturally people are not happy with this
and uh i talked about this earlier on my
other channel but this is
well coveted cases are on the rise
basically everywhere people are scared
of the delta variant
and now we're seeing draconian measures
like in france
over in australia we're getting mixed
signals i suppose
katie hopkins has been deported because
apparently she broke quarantine or
something like that
and a bunch of other celebrities have
come in and been given special leeway
and special access but
i'm not super concerned necessarily
about the double standard at this point
because
we know that exists i suppose i'm more
concerned about with whether or not the
rise in coveted cases the delta variant
is going to result in more lockdowns
which joe biden says
well it's not off the table so we'll
talk about this and we're going to talk
a lot about uh
i guess why we don't like cities and
we're we're being
we're being joined by a home center and
author travis corcoran do you want to uh
introduce yourself real quick
sure uh thanks tim uh so i am a
homesteader and i am an author uh my day
job
is you know 50 hours a week as a
software engineer um
and uh you know homesteading is
something that on the one hand i do on
the weekends that's when i'm out fixing
the tractor and planting the pumpkins
and butchering the pigs and all that
sort of stuff but uh
it also impacts one's entire life sort
of monday through friday and that um
you know my wife and i talk a lot about
how we really love the fact that you
know fifty percent of our food comes
right off of the farm and every morning
the bacon is from our pigs can you put
your mic up a little bit
yeah sure sorry um and you know the eggs
are from there and uh
you know when we make whatever even
tacos that's you know coming from uh
beef that have processed um and then
there's also a lot of resiliency to
living on a homestead uh which ties into
the whole covid thing
and uh you know this is i'm here to some
degree to talk about some books that
i've written
escape the city volumes one and two and
uh the timing was perfect on this
because when covet hit you know a whole
lot of people in the cities their
lifestyles just you know
turned uh terrible and there's obviously
the whole real estate realignment that's
going on right now where real estate
prices
are absolutely crashing in every city
core and you're seeing you know huge
price run-ups in other places as you
know half the country redistributes
where it works
fleeing the city right yeah um and so
it's good to hear that they're taking uh
jackpot's advice and
my advice right and your advice escape
the city hopefully
uh the kickstarter did well and the
book's now up on amazon so uh the advice
is there for anyone who wants it
we're gonna talk a lot about what's
going on with this lockdown stuff i mean
this this stuff in france
is absolutely draconian but then uh an
optimistic solution
because i've been i've been saying this
a long time like i actually was saying
this today
it's so amazing i'm looking out my
window and i'm recording these videos
forest
there's like deer running around there
doing deer stuff and then i see him like
going for the paw paw and i'm like
getting nervous like oh they're gonna
take it
but apparently it's it's don't have to
worry because they're not ripe yet so
the deer won't go near them i just got
to make sure we get them before the deer
take them but it's a lot of fun so we'll
talk about this stuff uh ian's chilling
yeah i was out in the woods over the
weekend i think it was over the weekend
picking some wine berries and man i was
getting scratched up by the brambles
getting my hair cut in the trees and it
felt great i felt alive i felt connected
with nature i felt like it was
enhancing my immune system by giving me
just a little bit of those cuts you know
a little bit of that dirt as long as
you'd wash it off when i went took a
shower
ian crossland in the house what up
everybody and i am also here i did not
go out and find wine berries but i'm
really excited to try this wine wine
once it's done i'm really curious what
it tastes like wine wine so wine berries
are a local
uh well actually they're not local
they're an invasive asian uh
variant of raspberries and they're
everywhere in appalachia so you drive
down the road and you see red berries
everywhere they're amazing they're just
great pop them right off
and so we're going to make a little bit
of wine wine i'm super excited you have
better invasive species here in
the maryland dc area than we have up in
new hampshire we've got japanese
knotweed and
bittersweet and i am out there you know
every weekend with a pick and shovel
digging that stuff up
you know at first we have stink bugs too
and they're everywhere they're they're
insane
and at first i was upset about it then
we got chickens
mmm now now it's like ooh stink bug like
food to the chickens
right and they love the little things
man so we're we'll get into all that
stuff
we're gonna start with we're gonna start
dark and then move into the
the more optimistic before we do head
over to timcast.com my friends we have a
very brand new website that is
finally up actually went up on saturday
that surprised me i was like it's going
to be monday but it'll probably be late
and it goes up on saturday
uh obviously there's some bugs we're
launching it is now the official beta
because we're in alpha
so you may encounter some bugs but trust
me we are working around the clock to
make sure it works properly we got the
the brand new news section tons of
articles are going up we're doing
an abs like we have a lot of news being
published we're gonna be hiring more
people
as a member you'll get access to the
members only segment we'll have a bonus
members only podcast coming up after the
show goes up on 11 or so p.m so make
sure you sign up
and don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel hit that
notification bell even though probably
doesn't do anything
and uh share the show with your friends
it's the most important thing
instead of us spending all this money on
marketing which we don't have like you
know cnn puts up billboards and buys air
time in airports of which i guess they
don't do any more
we just rely on word of mouth so with
your support thank you very much go to
tmpis.com now
let's read this first story and talk
about what's going on we got this from
timcast.com
australia sends mixed signals on who is
permitted to enter the country
deports katie hopkins they say despite
permitting the arrival despite
permitting the arrival of celebrities
come on tim cast get a copy editor the
government has not brought home
40 000 australians now the article
basically goes on
to mention that there are many
celebrities flying in like you know
you've got what they say nicole kidman
flew in you have lachlan murdoch and um
keith urban where among the elite group
have been allowed to travel back to the
country by a
private plane they were also permitted
to quarantine at their private homes
they go on to mention that uh there we
go british commentator katie hopkins
who was also in australia to film big
brother was deported
for comments she made online about
breaking the corn uh country's
quarantine regulations
so we've seen a lot of this lockdown
stuff going on and now uh basically the
story is australia is prolonging its
covet 19 lockdown in victoria
amid the delta outbreak so this is the
excuse by which they're saying
everyone's got a quarantine again if
you're flying into the country and it
kind of
um i got i got to say it is it is
awfully convenient
if you are a proponent of the great
reset are you familiar with the growth
absolutely
it's it's awfully um fortuitous i
suppose for those who are fans of the
great reset and
those who have advocated for it that uh
we can't travel the places anymore
that people are deported if they you
know they break quarantine i get it the
country has laws australia's allowed to
deport where they want i suppose
but now they're prolonging this now
there's fears of of uh you know the
delta uh the delta variant outbreak
and i'm just you know i'm curious you
mentioned um
in the in the intro we're talking about
people fleeing these cities
what's your what's your i guess your
prediction on where we are um
you know i've got some thoughts about
the current month in the current year uh
but we were talking before the show
rolled about you know i think the world
is changing in a really fundamental and
big way and the kind of thing that you
don't see every year i mean sure things
change you know one year and the next
uh but you know i think that every 500
years or so
things really really change and we saw
that you know uh around 500 years ago
with the
invention of the printing press which
led to the rise of protestantism and
religious wars and then eventually the
westphalian nation states
coming up and replacing feudalism and
you know i think the internet and the
new modes of communication technology
right now
are you know and this isn't a story from
like last year or two years it's you
know the
30 years 50 years but the world is
really changing fundamentally and i
think we're going to see changes at
about the same scale so
i think that people are escaping the
cities right now and that's going to
accelerate over the coming years
but that's just one component of a much
bigger change in
currency and lifestyles and economies
and how
you know states and people are organized
on the planet do you think it's uh
intentional like there are people who
are actively trying to
kill off cities obviously well you know
there's
intention out there and there's emergent
stuff i don't think that the elites
who are pushing the great reset and the
whole you know live in the pod eat the
bugs
uh want people to escape the cities you
know they're saying hey uh you know our
system is already 80
along and we just need to tune it a
little more we need you know more green
energy
even though windmills are sort of a
terrible technology and nuclear is much
better
and we need more sustainable foods and
by sustainable they're always talking
about bugs uh
and never about you know raising pigs
and chickens and you know eating
right right wine berries they're saying
not to eat pigs and chickens right right
right right right right right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
two eat the bugs right right did you see
that story out of leesburg virginia
where the
the guy was serving cicadas i didn't
know he was like going into his
like his side of his house and picking
them off yeah and then i guess the
health department was like dude you
can't pick bugs off inside your house
and serve it to people uh-huh
so we had he ordered cicadas right now
i'm like but i i guess they were from
china
so it clearly defeats the purpose right
right eating sustainable bugs from the
floor
ship them in by air or something yeah
right just eat the centipedes
yeah yeah so anyway sorry you i don't
know oh uh so
um i i think your question was was this
intentional getting people to flee the
cities and i think what's intentional
is the great reset the whole endless
propaganda about how eating bugs and
your lifestyle is going to be different
and you're not going to own anything
you're going to rent everything
and uh you know i i think that a lot of
that is intentional
but i think that we're to some degree
seeing the last gasp of the current
system uh sort of like you know the
soviets around 1985
um the current elites have run out of
any energy i mean the soviets motivated
their people
you know is a terrible system but there
was actual um
grassroots enthusiasm when you bring
rural electrification to people you know
they're gonna like that even if you're
doing other terrible things when you
educate the sons of dirt farmers they're
gonna like that
um and so the soviets had some innate uh
momentum for decades and then eventually
they just played out everything they
could do
and then you know they're talking about
the 18th five-year plan and you know
1986 or something and everyone knew it
was a joke and
the soviets in the system said you know
they pretend to pay us and we pretend to
work
and i i think that you know the last
bastion of centrally planned uh
communism is you know here in the west
uh so what is what
what is that i mean i'm joking a little
bit and making a reference to sort of uh
mentious mold bug courtesy arvin stuff
but no but you mean to say like the
current system we're under
everybody knows it's a joke and i think
exactly that's where i was going you're
right
right um you know uh you know we've got
and don't worry i know what one can say
and not say um but we've got a
democratic party
uh the republican party ceased to be
able to put forward any candidates of
its own sort of ideology
and the democratic party has sort of
entirely run out of steam where they're
putting forward these candidates who
it's inevitable because it's their time
and you get these you know sort of
absolute laughing stocks
hillary clinton right right um so and
you know uh
joe biden god help him does not seem to
have all of his marbles uh in one place
he's got like two marbles right right
you know it's a tragedy um but
this is the last gasp of the system you
know and so they pretend to have a
president and you know we pretend to
respect the system
and uh i think that things are changing
um i i like that joke you know they they
pretend to parents who pretend to work
they can have a president i think the
sad thing is yeah it's paper thin
yeah you know they're they're there's a
presidential administration joe biden
is fumbling bumbling joe trina shabbat
of pressure batacath care
and you know one thing that i brought up
on the show uh frequently is that when
he speaks it's very obvious he's not
talking to half the country
right he'll when he he makes references
to covet when he makes references to law
they've basically cut off in terms of
their there was a point where they were
like
you know we want to try and make sure
we're getting to the other side to win
those votes now they're like we don't
even care
yeah we don't don't care about this we
saw in the in the 1900s 20th century the
the fall of like centrally planned
economies very clearly and now i think
we're up against the centrally planned
law
lawyering system and i wonder how we can
i like how you said poly
as opposed to decentralized polycentric
law
and how we would do that while
maintaining a union
right how do you foresee that uh i'm not
sure we maintain a union i mean
um you know every system lives for as
long as it lives uh back in college i
double majored as computer science but
also roman history
and um one of my professors i think
barry strauss had a
a wonderful um last lecture in the
semester one year
and uh you know he was talking about the
parallels between the roman system and
the american system
and uh you know he said a few things
that you know every country ends
eventually
uh but also its forms linger on after
the reality of it has died
and uh you know a lot of people um
your sort of red grey tribe will say you
know you know america has gone so far
off the rails but we'll get it back and
i'm like you know dude i think america
ended somewhere between
10 and 50 years ago and right now you
know we still have the form of it
some some people argue it ended with the
federal reserve i think that's you know
i i don't particularly have the federal
reserve bug
um that you know that explains
everything um but uh but but i can get
along with those guys um you know i i
think that
uh there's good arguments that um
oh gosh um not coolidge anyway
i'm blanking in my earlier woodrow
wilson yes thank you very much sir
um and there's another argument to go
further back that abraham lincoln and
you know even if freeing the slaves was
a
wonderful ideal uh it's interesting how
every other country on the planet
managed to free its slaves without
having a war and killing three percent
of its population
yeah and many before us yeah like the
the british empire exactly
perfect example uh great britain proper
i think was in the 1700s
was it like 73 or something or 75 uh i
would have thought it was later than
that but i'll trust your number
i could be wrong i know that the in in
the greater commonwealth it was 1833
right right that's that's the number i
had in my head it's funny because they
freed their slaves but they still have
like colonized
india completely so like right right you
know and the united states is an example
of that but um you know
we talk about you know we're this
exemplar for all mankind this wonderful
free society where anybody can do
anything you know as long as it's in the
properly approved narrow set of things
that are good and free not you know
terrible bad things like you know
going to church and having old-fashioned
ideas or owning firearms or anything
um and yet we have this crazy system
where
members of both parties sort of support
this imperial war-mongering system where
we're
fighting in you know 30 or 40 different
countries uh so we've got this
representative government and all these
freedoms at home
to some degree while simultaneously we
have you know
absolute you know uh um
on what is the word i'm looking for with
without feathered yes
unfettered that'll do uh you know we
have this effect of war on anyone we
want to and there's no checks and
balances and there's no civil rights
it's crazy to me how at a certain point
the united states the the politicians
stopped actually implementing policy in
this country and it was actually an
argument over what we should be doing
overseas right
and we had a long period of that for my
mind look i can't argue for
about what happened before i was born
but i thought most of my life was just a
whole lot of arguing about what we're
going to do to other people elsewhere
and i long complained i'm like
everybody's coming out talking about
these pipes in flint
which which now i believe are fixed but
i'm like how much money did we spend in
afghanistan building roads and building
schools right
so it's it's weird to me that the answer
to a lot of what the left was
complaining about was simply that we
focus on america first which is
controversial i guess for some strange
reason
but but i want to i want to go back to
this point about uh you know katie
hopkins in australia because
you mentioned there might not be a union
and so i'm wondering
if these these these countries are
effectively shutting their borders off
they're making it much much more
difficult for anyone to come in what is
it going to look like if
if the united states isn't even going to
be a union but then it's already hard
enough for people to travel it feels
like
everybody is becoming more isolated yes
um you know so there's an interesting
thing where things are getting
physically more isolated you know
in the physical realm of where can you
go at the same time
that distance is becoming less important
and this is the whole sort of lexus in
the olive tree thesis that you know the
world is getting flat
and you know you can source parts from
wherever and you can you know i work for
a startup that doesn't have a physical
location
we're decentralized we've got people you
know all the way from italy over to
japan so we've just got this sort of
weird rolling 20 hour clock
um but you know this gets to what i was
saying earlier about
uh you know every 500 years or so maybe
there's a deep fundamental change in how
society is structured now
getting the covet i think that this is a
short-term problem there's you know we
sequenced uh covet 19
in very short order and we came up with
a immunization for it in you know 48
hours
and the only thing that stood in the way
was the old you know nation states and
the fda and the cdc
uh you know doing things like taking
four day weekends uh
during the emergency where you can count
the number of people dying per day
but they're so entrenched in the sort of
1970s soviet bureaucratic thing of oh
we've all got to get out to our dodges
you know
this is you know soviet pioneer day you
can't expect us to work and save lives
then
so i i think that's proof that the
system is absolutely exhausted and it's
just
ready for people to stop believing it
when you look at the sheer tribalism
you know like i mentioned and many
people have mentioned joe biden seems to
only be talking to one side of the
country at this point because they've
basically resigned themselves okay we
can't win them over it's over we're done
we're done talking
i mean the the tribalism has reached
absolutely absurd levels
you know it's like that right now that
people are people are circulating
these old tweets from 2020 of kamala
harris and like daily coast writing
about
vaccine skepticism and they're saying
like who would take trump's vaccine
and now they're the ones screaming like
why won't trump supporters take the
brexit absolutely yeah people are
absolutely aligned
i i gotta say you know perhaps i'm just
biased but
i think it is fair to say that it is
indeed it is it is uh the rule
for the establishment left but the
exception for
the right in general so leftists kind of
overlap with a lot of the establishment
democrats
but you look at you mention the
republican party in the in their you
know forever war kind of stuff too
i want to make clear that i don't think
that's just the republicans i mean both
parties are forever but i will say like
i think as as another sign of the
of of the collapse or the decay or the
change whatever you want to call it
is donald trump's storming into the
republican party and forcing dramatic
changes right
and trump supporters he couldn't have
done that in 1980 or 1984
you can't uh one man with a bunch of
bombast can't knock over a healthy
system
but the trump supporters i i don't know
if you
did you hear what michael moore said
back in 2016 i think i did i remember
being shocked that he was sort of
intellectually honest about it for the
first time
it was it was brilliant he basically
said that trump was one of the only
people advocating for these factories
he goes to these auto manufacturers and
said i will i will tear a few 30
if you try and move these cars out of
america and and then
michael moore said the workers look at
donald trump like like a human molotov
cocktail
and they are going to send the biggest
few to the establishment the world has
ever heard and they are going to enjoy
it
the one thing he got wrong was he was
like it'll feel good for a week
or a month that felt good for four years
i know yeah it felt good for a lot of
people for a while
so i think that's one of the big changes
to the republican party but i think
you know uh so just to address that
point on the left you have many people
who are
it's it's crazy how they can't remember
what they said last year you know i uh
started flipping back through 1984
recently and everyone's read 1984.
and there's a problem with reading
things you tend to boil them down to an
essence or a logo or something and and
things in the world
books uh novels people have a whole lot
of complexity so
to actually go back and look at 1984 um
it's
not just sort of a stand-in or a
stereotype or a glyph that stands for
repressive totalitarianism there's a lot
of detail there
and the detail about how the party just
changes the line and everyone
you know switches on a dime and this is
what we're seeing
um you know last year you know i was one
of these internet autists who was paying
attention to china in
very very early january and i think it
was late january
when you know i started tweeting my ten
thousand you know i'm talking to tim
pool about i've got 10 000 followers on
twitter
um but i said you know guys now is the
time to start packing uh
stockpiling stuff and people said you
know what and i said you know i don't
know that
you know if it surfaces but start
getting latex gloves in case it does
turn out to be surfaces i don't know if
it's airborne
but definitely start getting masks you
know p90 p95
start laying in food i'm not saying
there will be supply chain disruptions
but when you don't know
and at that time the left and uh oh gosh
what was he uh
ezra um yes thank you i think it was
either ezra klein or if it wasn't ezra
klein it was one of the other ezra
kleins
was absolutely pooh-poohing this idea of
you know masks do nothing and even if
they do anything you should leave it for
the professionals there's no reason to
have a mask
and the fear that you'll generate that's
the real danger and then they all pivot
on a dime
when you know the new line comes down
from the you know
there used to be journalists if you're
familiar with that you know the journal
the journal list oh yeah there's more
than people know man right and and so
certainly there are dozens more
journalists and when you see
so let's let's break that down real
quick sure he's not saying journalist
he's saying
journal hyphen list this was i think
ezra klein made this right
it was a it was a facebook group where
all of these different journalists from
different organizations were on
one community group together so one
person would come in and say
x happened and then every single
journalist would you know in this group
would see it
so they were all wrapped up in the exact
same bubble narrative
completely oblivious to the outside
world there's a wonderful video on
youtube
that shows uh some people on a cable
channel reading out a prepared statement
and like every five second it switches
to a different cable channel and the
statement continues seamlessly
because this was literally a memo that
came down from corporate and they wanted
every local affiliate to do it
journalist was effectively the same
thing but there wasn't a corporation at
the top there was just this little
plate or file or hive of journalists and
they had tamara's bullet points every
day
so people don't realize about that is
there wasn't one journal list
there was probably ten thousand right i
was personally on several of them yeah i
think i still am on one i was on
i was on there there were a bunch of
good ones there was one that was about
it was like
um citizen journalist centric so it was
basically
10 or 20 000 people with several who are
very active and many who just followed
and they would post things and they
would all see it and then sure enough
these articles pop up everywhere
but i i do want to with that being said
go back to the point you were making
about
you know it's time to prepare it's time
to buy supplies
because early early on last year
you know we we have one one of the
sponsors we often do is for a food
bucket
awesome safe and ready meals this is not
i'm not promoting them i'm just
mentioning that we have from them in the
past
and this is like a 25-year food bucket
now i
i don't i don't like doing promos like
legit people like i'll get sent like hey
tim would you want to advertise for this
and i'm like no i can't do that company
you know like i have to actually think
there's utility there
and so this company i thought was
actually fantastic because
the way i describe it to people is you
know you've got a first aid kit right
i've got multiple firsts right how many
but i don't know four or five including
trauma bandages
um i go into that in my books in that uh
you know i've got a small first aid kit
in my workshop
i've got a beefier first aid kit in my
chainsaw supplies right now
now here's a question though sure how
often do you use them uh
you know there's sort of the 80 20 rule
or the power law and that you know i
probably cut my fingertips or something
every you know
two weeks or so i think i actually did
it once every two weeks
yeah you might need to manage right how
often do you eat food
right yeah you know i think you eat food
yes three times a day
and so it's crazy to me that you know
that there's this negative connotation
uh this negative perspective
on having emergency food or whatever and
i'm like you should have a thing of
water food and a first aid kit
and and you know you look at what
happened with there was around the time
a camera actually i don't remember when
this was there was flooding in houston
it was really really bad and i'm like
some of these people are like trapped in
their houses for a long period of time
you're gonna be happy you can crack open
that freeze-dried sealed bag and
now you need some power to to boil the
water and stuff like that
you know but i look at it like it was
strange to me
that the establishment doesn't prepare
for anything right you know
you mentioned they turn in a dime the
the party says
so be it and they all just agree and
they're all in this mentality that no
matter what happens they will always be
safe and that to me is insane
absolutely i look you know you know what
i think here's what i always say about
buying beans and rice or these emergency
food kits
if you're in your absolute worst case
scenario
okay admittedly your worst case you have
food right you know but in the absolute
best case scenario
you literally you just eat it yeah like
i used to say look worst case scenario
just eat the food right and then i
realized no the worst case in here would
be the actual apocalypse and then you'll
eat the food right
but if you buy these things and then
nothing happens
the other day i just cracked it open
made some stroganoff it was delicious
put some chicken in there and some
spices
and i've absolutely done the same thing
not recently but you know i've had a
pile
you know one or two boxes of mres
sitting around the house forever since
you know shortly after i got out of
college
and uh you know every now and then you'd
be sort of working late and suddenly
it's uh 10 o'clock and there's no food
in the fridge and there's no take out
you know i've eaten an mre at 10 30 in
the evening more than once
yeah you know it's not something you
want to eat all the time right they're
not bad yeah
it's good self-limiting in that way
you're never going to be tempted to eat
up all of your eyes
well let's talk let's talk about this
you know right now you mentioned
uh in the previous segment that we could
be coming to this five year 500 year end
cycle i mean you've heard of the fourth
turning
yeah yeah you said he's trapped and now
we've got the mit study that everyone's
talking about
2040 the clash is coming or whatever
there's yet another one i'm going to
mispronounce the word but it's like
coral of wave theory
oh and we should add it to the list we
can talk about that one
you know i i think i ended up picking
this up from an
interstitial essay in a book of john
barnes short stories like 30 years ago
um and the idea is that there's a bunch
of different ways sort of sinusoids and
some have four-year
cycles another 12. and you know at some
point if you've ever you know taken
calculus or done a 4a you know
decomposition of something
you get a whole bunch of curves and they
start to peak up at certain points
and um you know the theory is that all
of these curves are going to peak
uh you know sometime way off in the far
future like 2025 or something
and you know this theory is written down
in the 70s or 80s and
i i think we're seeing a lot of it come
true you know stuff is getting crazy
so do you think you know you mentioned
last year you said people should buy
stuff
yeah what would you say right now do you
think people should be stocking up or
something like that um let me
i always want a little bit and say panic
right yeah yeah um panic never helps
anything um i think that anti-fragility
is a good thing and sort of the nesting
television love that idea
um and so you know people ask are you a
prepper i'm like well you know
i i'm not prepared to survive the zombie
apocalypse i don't want to survive a
nuclear war
you don't want to you know i i'm saying
maybe for humor i'd rather not die if
there's a nuclear war
um but the point is all sorts of things
happen and it's always better to be
prepared for them
one thing i talk about just you know
this isn't a survivalist or a prepper
book
um and i've got some sort of
anti-prepping thought and that's an
escape from the city right
escape from the city and uh this is a
recent homesteading
uh book that i wrote i've been on the
homestead for eight years and there's
two volumes volume one
and volume two wow and uh it's basically
one long book about 1300 pages long
and the uh you know it's sort of massive
in the amount of detail inside
uh you know the table of contents alone
is 30 pages so if you've got any
interest
in homesteading or uh prepping um i'd
recommend picking it up
it's escape the city it's on amazon and
they made prepping a dirty word yeah um
you know the problem with anything
is that it gets an ideological stink um
and so there's always this constant
recycling of language whether it's the
name of for a minority
or um you know intellectually challenged
person or
a hobby you know um and so you know
prepping uh
there's always uh an impetus in the
media to find someone and point at them
and laugh and then everyone laughs along
with you and you know sort of the
journalist
goes out that we all agree as a society
that you know preppers or furries or
whatever you know
we can punch down at them because
they're a bunch of weirdos uh in the
same way that we're punching down at
people who are buying masks
last of january so anyway um
my thoughts about prepping are there's a
power law in that absolute huge
catastrophic things happen very very
rarely but sort of very small annoyances
happen more often so if someone says you
know i want to be prepared what should i
do should i get a
zombie hunter extreme machete should i
get a long-range sniper rifle i'm like
you know maybe you should get 500 in the
checking account because
uh you know people get laid off like
once every five years so you're gonna be
laid off from your job but you know in
the next five years certainly in the
next 10 years
so lock down how you're going to survive
that without you know losing your
lifestyle
um you know people lose their power once
every 10 or 15 years plan for that and
that's not expensive you get a 500
generator a 300 transfer switch um but
then
you keep going out on these things and
they're less and less frequent um
but the chance you know hopefully we'll
all live to be 70 or 80 or 90.
and a thing that only happens once every
15 years that's going to happen to you
several times in your life
and we in the west we've been you know
rich and protected by oceans and so
we've been uh
very you know blessed and we've not had
a lot of the bad stuff that normal
people have at the same
rate that they have it but i wrote this
book starting several years ago and one
thing i said is
hey we get plagues about once every
hundred years we had the spanish flu in
1918 and i went back several other
plagues so you should be prepared
because there's a decent chance that
there'll be a plague
in your lifetime um do you hear about uh
this this story happened several years
ago there was an algebra
in the great lakes and within 40 which
is toledo on the lake
i can't remember which city it was
western
there was within 40 miles i guess of all
these cities
no drinking water wow because what
happened was as soon as the news broke
as soon as people found out they
immediately started raiding
local stores for bottled water and
moving further and further out to get
more and more water and then within 40
miles
no water what do you drink my wife made
a really interesting point that one of
the reasons to prep is not because it's
the only way to get the supplies
the reason to prep is so that you don't
have to make terrible trade-offs when
you need the supplies um and you know
the terrible trade-off could be as
simple as paying ten dollars a gallon
for gasoline to run your generator
uh or it could be a lot worse and i mean
you know uh people especially women in
refugee camps all the time
have to make terrible trade-offs you
know i went crazy with vinegar and salt
people are laughing at honey honey like
hunt like 100 pounds of money
because if it does go down i want to
provide it for the neighbors
i want the entire community to be
preserved as much as possible so that we
can barter
so that if they have all the ammo if
they have you know whatever so we can
all kind of come together and those
things become extremely valuable
ian bought an absurd amount of salt
vinegar and honey never go bad
and we laugh mostly at the vinegar most
of the vinegar because like
i don't know what it's what you do with
it however i do understand it can be
used for a lot of chemical processes
so what's a funny idea that you'd have
so much vinegar because how often do you
really use it in some recipes
but in actuality it lasts forever
doesn't it as far as i know yeah
it does and i'm going to jump in and
defend ian because when you've got
vinegar you can pickle anything
so when your harvest comes in all over
four weeks but you want to store it for
the winter
you know just pile that under vinegar
and is that all you do you just put
vinegar yeah
you needed brine uh brine is salt so
ian's covered no exactly that's
so yeah i mean honey never goes bad
right right right
salt is is you definitely need salt like
you know where
where would you get your salt in your
diet if you're you know in an area like
this you know in appalachia yeah
is salt naturally occurring or uh you
know you know
if there was a disaster or something and
you had to improvise uh i would go with
road salt but other than that you know
you're going to be trading
people who are you know bringing in salt
from the ocean salt was the currency at
one point five six thousand years ago i
was
i was thinking about this earlier
because we bought some deer salt licks
oh yeah you just you know chuck them out
you live on them or something
and i see the deers going nuts from
because there's no salt right right and
so the deer when they find salt
there's a warning on it saying make sure
you put out several otherwise the deer
will fight each other to get it
because there's no salt so imagine if
you didn't have salt see this is a crazy
thing people don't realize
in in even you know we get out of the
city we're in the middle of nowhere
people still don't realize that we're
dependent on so much like
vitamin c for instance i don't know
where we would source vitamin c
out here we could probably try and grow
some stuff maybe because we're more
modernized we can grow stuff indoors and
try and grow some citrus or something
but where would we get vitamin c what's
your recommendation um for that i
i again i'm not a super prepper but uh
rose hips have vitamin c and we've got
roses in the yard so
yeah uh you know got wild roses yeah
just eat a bunch of roses yeah
wow boiled into tea yup absolutely way
to do it
can you uh boil grass can you work with
cat grass for food
i know you can't eat it directly
excessive cellulite yeah i don't think
there's many calories in grass
i i would feed grass to my sheep and
then eat the sheep so yeah
yeah yeah that's the easiest way to do
it chickens eat grass yes they do
but they can't uh subsist off of grass
right
um you know chickens uh will get a lot
of their calories from bugs and worms
yeah
and so we've got our chickens in a pen
but there's a thing that a lot of people
do which is a chicken
tractor and that has nothing to do with
a diesel-powered tractor it's basically
a mobile pin with wheels on it
and the idea is that you put your
chickens in this pen and then you just
go out and either with your riding mower
or your tractor or just by hand
you move it 10 or 15 feet a day chicken
city on wheels exactly
yeah we people have recommended it and
i've heard that people will put it over
where they want to farm
right let the chicks chickens tear it up
then move it and then they can plant
stuff in it and they fertilize it
so i've got a thought about this and
this is something i go into my book um
there's some utility in this you know
chickens are great pigs are great i
don't have pigs this year but in general
i have pigs like every other year
but people sometimes want to say oh man
you know and this is sort of like after
a deep bong hit you know the system you
know nature gives you everything you
need man
the pigs will furrow you know they'll
turn up the soil for you so you don't
need to till
and there's a little bit of truth here
but there's a whole lot more wishful
thinking and i've never
uh seen anyone who um says that pigs
will till your soil who actually have
their own pigs
it's uh to some degree wishful thinking
so the pigs are no good
pigs are great um but pigs do not
replace uh tractors or rototillers or
plastics yeah yeah yeah
so if uh you know what what should the
average person be buying like a time
right
well let me let me slow down we were
previously talking about
a dramatic change in that in the system
let's start from there what
what does this change look like do you
think right we've talked a lot about
like balkanization yeah
where the and i want to be clear on this
it's like the political factions
basically
choose their specific region and they
they break apart and move
do you think it's something like that
what do you think we're looking at um so
you know first of all i don't want to
really be certain about this
um i always find people who are
absolutely certain to be a little you
know if you've got a head scratching
attitude about that that you know
i don't know man you haven't seen the
future um but i think the interesting
thing about information technology
whether we're talking about the
gutenberg press or whether we're talking
about you know tcp
or twitter or whatever is that it
connects people who are further and
further apart with lower and lower
latency so
if you want to look at like 1776 um you
know people in
different towns in massachusetts had a
lot more in common with each other than
they had with people back in you know
wales or you know
various parts of england because they
could only communicate with a few
letters you know with a latency of six
months or so
and so that made it very easy for the
regions to sort of grow apart and have
their own uh political cultures
and the weird thing about the high speed
connection we have is that we have
you know uh two tribes obviously red and
blue but then a lot more tribes you know
if you go to you know some very fandom
thing right yellow
you know you pick anything whether it's
you know mustang uh
engine you know modification community
or whether it's
uh preppers or whether you know it's
anything guns yeah you'll
find that these tribes are
geographically distributed um so
i think that we might be headed to a
world where the westphalian nation state
where all of the nations have crisp
little borders around them
is perhaps fading and we're going to a
new world where the tribes are
interleaved and distributed across and
on top of each other i've been thinking
a lot about that dissolution of the
nation state since about 2006
really since internet video when i
realized how powerful and connected we
are now with video chat like
how do you see it happening without uh
because the downside was i don't want
a one world government that's
totalitarian right now i'm looking at
more of a decentralized localization
i mean you obviously work with crypto
like how do you see something like that
right um you know again you know i'm
gonna say i can speculate since you're
asking me to speculate
uh you know if you go back to the
medieval period there is this
interesting thing
where there was less of a crisp
boundary in the westphalian sense you
might have somebody who was
a you know in the example i i said
before the show started
is you can imagine that um there was
someone you know pedaling out on the
street and the guards come up and say
hey it's sunday you can't sell stuff and
he you know holds up his warrant and he
says you know actually i'm a jew
so i'm you know bound by different uh uh
doctrine doctrine right religious code
um but i'm
also tied in a little bit to your
political system and i've got a warrant
from the duke who says you know yes i'm
a jew with his permission i'm doing
things
and the answer is oh okay so you're on
the same territory as people who are
under this other power but you're under
a different sort of chain of command
whoa and um i can't imagine that being a
good thing
um you know when the world changes good
or bad doesn't really matter you know it
comes out of incentives
i think it might be a decent thing um i
think we're going that way
yeah i mean you look at the the racial
identitarianism from the establishment
in this country and it really does look
like that's where we're going yeah i
mean you know right now we're already in
that you know one person at harvard uh
is under a different law than someone
else depending on you know his skin
color um you know his admission there
the
behavioral norms that's expected and
everything else or actually you can't
even get into harvard if you're asian
right most parts right yeah absolutely
different different roles just based on
what you look like
and uh you know i there's little hints
of that that you know if someone is from
overseas and they've got diplomatic
plates we're here you know not too far
from dc and i saw that
so i think that polycentric law
overlapping in the same geographic uh
location
is something that has happened before in
the middle ages and i think it could
happen again
not making a strong prediction uh and
this ties into we're talking about
anarcho-capitalism and one of the sort
of leading luminaries
of anarcho-capitalism is david friedman
the son of milton friedman
and he's written a bunch of great books
on the topic uh the
seminal one is the machinery of freedom
which was one of the books that along
with robert heinlein's the moon is a
harsh mistress
really sort of created my worldview but
he's written some other good ones
law's order and uh one i read a few
months ago was legal systems very
different from our own
so uh i'm not sure we'll see what
happens over the coming decades i could
see like um an augmented reality system
where
when you look around people have like a
different aura if they're under
different jurisdictions
or something but my wonder is what if
the power goes out would that system
function could it function do you think
it was something that
um you know uh what if the power goes
out gets back to sort of robustness and
anti-fragility
and uh you know i i expect that
long-term uh technology is gonna stick
around
and that we will be living in a
hyper-networked world
so that sort of pulls in the opposite
direction of the sort of localism and
the anti-fragile homesteading that we're
talking about so
uh i don't know um you know in investing
some people talk about a barbell
strategy where
you want to have a lot of your money and
sort of safe reasonable things like
index funds but you also want to
have a small amount and really potential
high payoff bets
you know this is the venture capital
model and uh politically
uh looking towards the future on the one
hand you know sort of i hope for
everyone has you know human rights and
the uh power grid stays up and the food
supplies are good
uh but i also have sheep that i can eat
my own orchard and i can make my own
wine in case it goes bad
like we got to get off the grid the
central so we're getting off a
centralized economy centralized law
centralized electricity it's got to be
so let's let's let's central
you you know a lot about rome uh i know
some yeah when when rome collapsed
right the the as you mentioned before
latency i mean distance between
communications
was was very a very long time absolutely
and then you end up with their own zone
political cultures and then
you mentioned now we're in this you know
new era of technology
it's going to be really interesting in
my opinion just to elaborate on that
idea when you have
you know one faction of people maybe
it's a family and they're
anarcho-capitalists and they're online
communicating with the
anarcho-capitalist community
but they're decentralized their neighbor
is a socialist
their other neighbor is a conservative
you know you know free enterprise sort
of but still some government control
how how will there be cohesive law
if people when right next to each other
are just yeah
no it's a great question and i'll take a
stab at answering it but i again i want
to be clear that i'm not predicting that
like this is definitely the way it's
going to happen
uh david friedman talked about this and
uh he's the one who came up with sort of
polycentric legal order and what he said
is you know
uh you tim you know might subscribe to
one legal system where you want to keep
trespassers off your land that's pretty
important to you
uh someone else might subscribe to a
legal system that has a english right to
rome and then we uh in england
apparently if you've got a certain
amount of land you can't keep
people off it they they're allowed to
just walk right across as the sort of
traditional uh right of the englishman
so what happens when these you know
things come in conflict like one guy
says i've got an absolute right to walk
across your backyard and you say i've
got an absolute right to keep you out
and you know theoretically someone who
wanted to dis on an arc of capitalism
would say well you know then of course
you'd get a gun battle and that's why
narco capitalism is the worst possible
political ideological
ideology in the world um but you know
in in the real world when corporations
run into things like you know you've
stolen my intellectual property because
i think that my patent on you know how
resistors work is you know blah blah
blah and you say no
i'm using a different thing it looks
similar but it's not we don't get guns
and duke this out uh we you know we just
hire lawyers and they settle it
uh so i think that that would happen now
so now the next parity is
okay travis is arguing that anytime two
people have a disagreement about uh
trespassing in a garden like is there an
easement or is there not then there's a
90 000
lawsuit that takes three years and i i
think uh
there's game theory where when something
is iterated
there is not a need to hash it out time
and time and time again
both sides see you know really a
negotiated solution here and some rules
of the road make sense
so if you look at any place where uh
firms interact
they either come up with their own laws
or they come up with their own
governance bodies to help them interact
with each other because
you know if you look at evolution
animals don't battle to the death with
each other when you've got two rams and
they both want to you know
dominate the herd of use um it doesn't
make sense if one ram is aiming to kill
the other because he's likely to get
severely damaged in that the uh
utility maximizing compromise is some
sort of dominance display and head
bashing and then one of them sucks off
because he can live to try again another
day and uh i i think people are not
idiots people do not get into gun
battles they
i i i somewhat disagree um you look we
we talked about the wacky laws you know
recently where you've got some places
where it's like you can't take a shower
on tuesdays
and it actually made sense because back
in the day the local aquifer was like
you know
we like they said we have to have one
day where nobody uses water so it can
replenish a little bit
but now we have better water systems we
have tons of water so we we produce
these laws based on
the specifics that are happening in our
areas so you have a community
and they build a culture they build
rules and laws with before each other
by each other and sometimes and disagree
with each other but understanding the
problem
hey look a bear keeps coming in so we're
going to pass a law you can't have
picnic baskets
lying around wherever well now you've
got somebody who's on the internet
and he does not subscribe to any of his
immediate community
when they go outside they're clashing
and one guy's on nothing but socialist
forms and one guy's on nothing but you
know and cap forums
and so they're completely at odds
locally
i don't necessarily think that they
would just agree to resolve the solution
because the resolution itself is part of
the local community
culture and law that's a great argument
uh and i follow it and it's convincing
and um so now the great thing about you
know pontificating while sitting on my
butt is i can say okay if you didn't
like that answer
i've got another one and the other one
is that just as the
cost of information transmission is
falling the cost of picking up and
moving your butt is falling
you know i moved from massachusetts
where the local community and the norms
and the politics were very much not to
my liking and i moved to new hampshire
eight years ago
and uh a lot of end caps in new
hampshire there are uh
there's a joke um you know i don't know
if i would necessarily say that i'm part
of the free state project but i'm
certainly fsp adjacent and i know a lot
of fsp people
um and there's a joke you know what's
the difference between a libertarian and
an ancap and the answer is you know six
months in new hampshire
so uh you know i think picking up and
moving to be around people who are like
you
um is a good thing and there's a phrase
the great sort which is mostly talking
about demographics and mating but i
think that to some degree it's also
happening geographically
i completely agree i mean look at how
many people moved to texas recently
right joe rogan ellen musk announced it
but a ton of people
there's a lot of regular people that
moved and one of the things i've warned
though is that while you know joe rogan
and elon musk
are they seem to be left-leaning
individuals i mean elon musk calls
himself a socialist whether he is or not
i don't know
it's funny considering he's a master
troll that's right right right
but the the people they bring with them
when they move their companies and their
jobs they bring
people with them in their periphery who
are definitely
not going to agree with exactly what
happens there in texas
but i digress you know that being said i
do think there's a great sort happening
i mean look we
moved effectively to west virginia i was
living in new york
city only a few years ago moved to the
philly suburbs
now we're in the the mountains you know
essentia essentially
i say that because we're trying to by
the way i loved uh the drive out here
the deer
every day i look outside there's a
family a deer doing their thing and
uh you know i want to get away from the
city so we move closer and closer to
people who are
more and more like-minded for me i would
say it's not necessarily that the people
around here are are like-minded
but we agree to leave each other alone
right which is big
yeah absolutely where i keep finding a
the problem or a problem regarding this
whole concept of decentralized law is
if a community wants to pollute the air
because that can affect the entire globe
if it's done
on a mass enough scale if they're
pumping methane and carbon and
you know radioactive materials up into
the atmosphere to produce just pure
industry like hundreds of thousands of
people like for decades
could just destroy things like thousands
of miles away china or
polluting the water like the ocean like
dumping so
a lot of the plastic wastes i was going
to go there next yeah indian china
plastic
we've got all of these rules against
having you know plastic straws in the us
and really it's all coming from just one
small place
so are we ultimately will we need a
global like an overseer um
so you know my answer to this is that uh
freedom can only exist on the frontier
and you know america has got a really
unique libertarian culture you find a
few libertarians in other places but
it's endemic to uh you know the united
states um
and that's because of our culture we we
ran into it you know quote-unquote empty
uh which is you know
uh the western hemisphere was empty
because of the tragedy of uh
communicable diseases
but uh we evolved this idea of a
frontier because we had a frontier and
that's why you can sort of
never really communicate about some of
these topics with people in other parts
of the country
and so if i may plug something else
tim introduced me as an author and the
first things i wrote before the
homesteading books
were two anarcho-capitalistic novels
which pretty much have the thesis uh
that we can only achieve freedom out on
the frontier so the first one is the
powers of the earth which won the
prometheus award for best novel in
2018 and the sequel is causes of
separation
which won the prometheus award in 2019.
i think you are correct about that with
the freedom um the way i've described it
is
you know uh you know how uh gases
the molecules you know are bouncing
around quite a bit liquids a little bit
and then solids they're rigid
when you look at big cities i view it as
a solid all of these individuals stacked
on top of each other
and that that room to bounce around
erratically that's your freedom
the more people surround you the more
you push and it compresses
your sphere of freedom so it's it's
actually it's a really really easy way
to explain it i i love your analogy and
uh because i'm a nerd i'm going to make
it a little nerdier
the ideal gas law which is pv equals nrt
and uh you know it's a great analogy
because
uh one thing that happens when you add
more uh molecules that have this kinetic
energy or when you crush them in tighter
space
is the temperature goes up right and um
yeah absolutely
oh yeah or the system expands right
right you know so we can go to sort of
the carnot cycle that it pushes out
and uh you know the piston but we're
talking about compression so that energy
is getting released
yeah and uh the easiest way to explain
it is just playing the drums
that in order to play the drums you need
a massive sphere of freedom
you can't do it in the suburbs you might
be able to but you have to get
permission
hey you guys mind if we're playing the
drums i know you know the the the zoning
order laws say that
the ordinance says i can be noisy until
10 pm but then your neighbors get mad at
you and then you're fighting with your
neighbors
you talk to them they'll say okay play
the drums but only between these hours
or you okay make noise put on between
those hours
you can't play drums in the city right
you got you got one person above you one
to your left your right and one behind
you
and you play the drums and they're gonna
be like are you nuts
it's it's it's not about i can sort of
hear it it's you're literally banging
next to next door to me
like turn your music it's a movie trope
so people
people are stacked on top of each other
there's no room for freedoms
i i absolutely agree um one of the you
know there's a dozen or
five dozen reasons that i don't want to
live in a city and i can't stand the
city
but one of them is that i'm an introvert
and um you know
i i know people who often propose
systems like i've got one friend who is
proposing a hacker space and my answer
to a hackerspace is i have a hackerspace
it's my garage and i've got you know
mig welders and you know bandsaws and
lathes and everything i want to do and
so anytime i want to do a project
the tools are there and i'm first in
line and i don't have to wait for anyone
else
and i think that uh one of the reasons
that he likes the idea of the hacker
space is because
all of these things are up for
negotiation we get to come together as a
community and decide the rules for how
we should do this we get to come
together as a community
so what i would see is a cost which is
the interactions and the negotiations is
for him a benefit
and i think a lot of people who love
cities actually love the fact that you
have to negotiate
everything um you know they talk about
you know a certain sense of community
and you know
that and that's what makes new york city
great the fact that when you know one
person vomits on the subway that
everyone else helps everyone else walk
around it
um and uh i i don't like interacting so
if i want to play the drums and get my
meal pureed on
um you know i don't have to talk to 10
other people about it regarding pv
nrt this is a little bit of an aside i'd
like to hear what you think about this
when you
increase the pressure it either is going
to enhance the temperature or
or expand the system yep but it's just
for tubular systems the way that was
written out to get water i think it's to
get water out of your rails or something
um so you know pve equals nrt
the ideal gas law uh is what you would
use to describe a um
piston in a cylinder whether it's an
internal combustion engine or a sterling
engine
uh but it would also apply to say a
balloon so is it possible that as the
balloon expands
it causes the expansion causes friction
which is energy from outside of the
system to cause it to heat up faster
which causes it to expand faster which
causes more friction
which causes more heat and a faster so
you get
acceleration or
i think what you're saying is that the
more people live in close proximity the
faster the acceleration towards collapse
well maybe what i'm getting at is i
think that in order to explain free
energy this is totally off topic i'm
sorry but i want to talk about pvnr tv
we got to move on to that okay but in
order to um get free energy to explain
to the people scientifically we need to
explain inflation
in pv and rt well i was an analogy for
people
smashed on top of each other and then
fighting they have nowhere to go it's
going to raise the temperature
so i think um i i think it's going to
happen sooner
the this this excitement this collapse
this rage
uh one thing people need to realize is
that we're in a
low period with the election for the
president was last year there's no
real cycle right now this year so
everyone kind of just like exhausted
2022 is the midterms 2023 is the
presidential primary cycle followed by
24 the presidential cycle and that is
going to be ramping up worse
absolutely more extreme than we saw but
i do want to show this story real quick
and
the story itself i think is important i
don't think it's the most excitable
story it's from nbc
all children should wear masks in school
this fall
even if vaccinated according to
pediatrics group the american academy of
pediatrics is calling the new guidance a
layered approach
we had steve bannon on the show nice he
said
on august 15th when mothers start
learning about what their children are
being taught
there is going to be you know a ruckus
or there's gonna it's gonna
i don't know i don't know the exact word
but you know you get the point yeah
people are gonna lose it
and he's right i think a lot of the
critical race theory stuff
is gonna result in moms being shocked
and angered but this is already
happening yeah
oh absolutely absolutely now consider
when kids are back in school summer ends
i saw this story and i saw it on reddit
and i looked at the comments because the
first thing i thought when i saw that
they were that schools who wanted to
make kids wear
wear masks even if they're vaccinated my
immediate thought was
there is no way even the establishment
leftists the people who march on a dime
for the
for the establishment are going to be
okay with this because even though
we have seen to great lengths these
people are willing to contort themselves
this will snap their brains like a
rubber band and i was right
surprisingly the top comments on reddit
which is mostly leftists were like i
can't do this anymore i can't handle
this
one response was i'm a high school
teacher this is insane i will not be the
mass police i can't handle this
and it was just inundated people saying
this is nuts it's gone too far we're
losing control
but the funny thing is they were trying
to adhere to the narrative yep
like we have to do it but their brains
were just at that point where the rubber
band was gonna snap
seeing the person say i'm a high school
teacher and i just can't handle it
anymore and i'm like whether they want
to support the narrative or not
the rubber band is gonna snap back and
then something's gonna happen i don't
know what
yep maybe it actually stabilizes things
i see a lot of doom posting on twitter
from my tribe talking about oh gosh you
know the left is going further on this
and this and you know the 1984
totalitarian blah blah blah
we're all doomed and it's all over and
linear uh extrapolations i think are
always naive and wrong because there are
feedback loops
and um you know as stuff gets crazier
more and more people start saying i
you know i can't buy into this anymore
and i i think that we are rapidly
approaching that point
the cathedral or the you know um
political organization right now has
this plan that has worked for them and
it's worked for 20 or 30 or 40 years
which is you bang more and more about
racism
and it motivates the base and it gets
people out to march and it motivates
donations
and you know they did this for all four
years of trump
and you know there's a terrible thing i
mean it's hilarious but it's also
terrible
which is that the word racist and the
word nazi have lost
all power because you know racism is a
terrible thing and no one wants to be
you know
called a racist if it's meaningful and
nazis are you know the second worst uh
political thing after communism
and uh you know that's terrible and no
one wants to be called a nazi
and so at first they're saying you know
okay these literal nazis marching down
the streets are nazis you're like yes
they are they're saying terrible things
about jews
you know that's terrible and then next
they're saying you know this
guy who's not a nazi but he's got some
you know really bad opinions as a nazi
you're like yeah okay i guess that's
pretty nazi like
and then pretty soon you know my half
nigerian friend fred
is being a i'm like i a he's not a nazi
and b that word is now entirely
meaningless it doesn't matter anymore
right right it's not about the word
being meaningless the word can mean
whatever it wants i just don't care
right that's what i'm saying you know
what i've done something amazing when
half the population doesn't care
it's not about half the population it's
not half the population i don't care
about what these leftist rage bait smear
merchants care
for the same reason i don't care about
what people in liberia are saying about
me
it's a different country and it has
nothing to do with me right so when i
see these people who i know
live in wali world and and believe
nonstick garbage
i'm like they can say whatever they want
i'm over it i don't
view them as look the divide in this
country
has has grown so great right there's two
countries that it's more than that
it's beyond shatter and there's all
these different fractals it is it is
beyond
two countries it is beyond two countries
when i heard
this is the example i was every time joe
biden talking about lockdowns
when red states were doing the opposite
i was like that's it
it is very clear that he does not view
us as part of the conversation or as
part of the country or someone who needs
to be talked to
so when i see someone in the mainstream
media nbc or whatever say something i'm
like why do i care what they think yep
it is not part of the world i live in
and and i didn't start it i'm just
responding to it absolutely
my friend adam uh said something really
interesting a month or two back which is
you know i think his exact words were
i'm really realizing more and more
that i'm a patriot of com of a country
that never really existed
and i think you know if you look at
twitter and other places people on the
right are saying
you know effectively i don't know what i
believe in i you know believe in this
1950s world but also the 1950s world was
maybe more an
artifact of marketing than reality oh
yeah and people on the left
you know they march but then the world
isn't operating the way they think it's
supposed to operate and their models are
broken
there's a huge cultural malaise or on we
or something going on because
all of the old explanations and answers
have broken down and uh you know joe
biden isn't motivating anyone
there's no narratives that are
motivating anyone and uh
we're discovering the new world right
now it's true man we ended slavery
but china didn't and we buy products
from china
that are getting made by slaves so we're
basically still supporting slavery yeah
no i mean we have companies that you've
you've that have used sweatshop labor
for a long time
like in the uh it is blatant
structurally you know in the economy and
i'll tell you this because
out at occupy wall street they had a
memorial for steve jobs
that to me was the funniest things now
it's not like it's not like the people
of occupy all came together and voted
here here we all agree
but many people there set up a memorial
because he died in october of
2011. and i i was laughing at just like
the absurdity of one of the most
ruthless cutthroat capitalist
businessmen who exploited
chinese communist slave labor it's being
propped up by these people at occupy and
i was there and i'm just like
and you know what i i've i i've
long known because i worked in
nonprofits that it's it's all marketing
it's all pr it's all it's all an attempt
to gain support but i think what happens
is
the internet allows for you know we used
to have five tv channels
or whatever three if you're older yeah
three right yeah and everyone just
agreed with like the narrative coming
from these channels the overton window
was an inch
wide that's right now with the internet
the overton window extends
for the most part from like the center
right to the far left
it's kind of hilarious that that's true
the mainstream will allow these
conversations
they'll wag their finger at the center
right right right and they'll you're so
naughty or the far left
right but but anyway the main point is
that it allows the entirety of the
political compass to
exist now in the space even if we can
say the overton window doesn't include
the far right
the authoritarian right and even and for
some reason and caps get lumped in there
sometimes
i mean i i think the uh overton window
includes
uh just enough republicans that they
they the cathedral or they the um you
know sort of central political
organization
can say oh we're tolerant we accept
everyone up to john mccain
um and you know maybe mitt romney on a
good day but regardless of what the
cathedral
cathedral thinks there are online
communities for literally everything
absolutely
and it's glorious i love it yeah yeah i
mean it used to be
um much much harder it was much more
centralized more of a
now it's it's evened out quite a bit but
i do think this is causing
a lot of our problems especially when
you know so
we're seeing this shuffling this this
great sorting algorithm is kind of
happening
west virginia is losing residence right
and one of the stories i read was about
a teacher and she gave an interview and
she was like what they're doing to the
unions and how they treat us is absurd
and the state is racist so i'm leaving
i'm going to austin or something like
that
or you know some other city and i'm like
isn't it fascinating
that in the in one of the west virginia
i think is the second
most trump supporting state from 2020
and you have the people who are
democrats
outraged and leaving meanwhile you have
the more conservative types from cities
outraged and leaving right everything's
being sorted
it's almost like we're in this big um
you know sieve or whatever and it's
being
shaking and some are falling through and
some aren't yeah so i i wonder
the fascinating thing about this is you
know we i've talked about civil war
quite a bit
and right now we have this poll showing
the balkan
potential balkanization it's i did the
math 37.2 percent of the population
is in favor of their region balkanizing
you know my father
is a real centrist republican uh you
know sort of mitt romney republican and
i had the pleasure of seeing my folks
over this past weekend after a year and
a half because of covet and my dad this
sort of you know
mainstream whatever media tv is telling
me you know he's talking about you know
we need to break into two countries and
when you're looking at you know 75 year
old boomers who came up in the system
and they're saying
you know they're sounding like some
crazy neo-reactionary on twitter
uh man the world's gotten strange but
it's not neo-reactionary it's 47
of democrats on the west coast so what
we're seeing with this with separation
is
i'm not actually convinced it's going to
just be
you know so so one thing i've said
recently is that i think we're more
likely to break up than see civil war
yeah but but i'll stress with this great
sorting that's happening
it's entirely possible we do see the
country split
along on hard lines you know we're
definitely not going to see civil war
because wars happen when you've got a
lot of young men and our population
structure uh
will not support a war you know um
there's just not enough cannon fodder
neil stephenson a great science fiction
author one of my favorites um
has had the sort of future history of
loosely linked books
and uh he has sort of you know crazy red
tribe rural areas and crazy blue tribe
rural areas
and somehow they coexist and i think
that sometimes governments just get
exhausted and don't have the political
will
to enforce hegemony and um you know i
think that we're to some degree
stepping into that world right now um
where we get soft secession
that you know maybe the tax dollars keep
filing back to washington and you know
maybe the bomber bases still
sit here but we're not going to listen
to the laws we don't want to and we've
seen that with marijuana legalization at
the state level
well but uh just thinking about what
what if we have
what if we end up with multiple layers
of governments going on at once
one while the electricity's on and one
if it goes off and it's like a
contingency
well let's let's be real for a second
what do you think is going to happen to
these blue areas
when the collapse or the disarray
happens or
the you know you know it's a red tribe
talking point that you know oh you know
the blue areas they're all fashion
designers and accountants and there's a
totally fake economy there and these
people don't produce anything whereas
out here in steel and corn country this
is the real world
and uh you know i i i understand
the uh emotions behind that um that the
blue tribe often doesn't see the
red tribe virtues they don't appreciate
hard work and diligence and you know
breaking bones and getting sweaty and
all these other things and so you want
to believe that you know
there are feet losers bug men living in
pods um and then my books by the way
start out i think there's
uh you know on on the dedication page
that you know this is to robert heinlein
who taught us not to be bug men living
in pods
um but the blue areas do huge amounts of
useful things and we're not going to you
know if there were a civil war
we're not going to surround boston for a
second time and starve them out because
they export intellectual property and
they've got a port and all of the food
they ever want to buy
is going to come in from the world so
i'm not predicting a collapse and i'm
not predicting civil war um
i think a peaceful divorce would be
great i think both sides would do okay
afterwards
in a peaceful divorce um it wouldn't be
both sides you know
there's no real way to split the country
in two but there there there could be
five regions
and there could be a bunch of different
regions you know where where where do uh
you know i mean california produces a
massive amount of food
for the country and for the world but
i'm not convinced that the farmers in
tulare who are mostly trump supporting
republicans
are going to be like sure i'll give my
food to these hippie lunatics in the
cities right well
give or you know are subject to uh a
regulation by i mean if
conquered yeah um i don't know that
either side uh really has the manpower
to do that i think that we are going to
see if there is a great divorce which i
don't think is super likely but i hope
we do
uh if there is a great divorce i think
china comes in then
well so that's the other thing if you
look at the us revolution the u.s
revolution only succeeded because there
was a great power war going on
where england didn't have the ability to
fight us because they were busy fighting
france
and if you look at how the us always
plays divide and conquer we're always
backing one faction overseas you know
the syrian
you know rebel group versus the other
one and so uh
you know i think china is going to get
old before it gets rich so
they are most dangerous for the next 10
or 20 or 30 years
but i don't think that the future of the
world is chinese but but but
if the us got into severe problems then
absolutely china would be funneling
money and weapons yeah and you would see
one faction in the united states side
with china
to win that would be crazed just like
the revolution man i don't i i
you know i look at these uh these
regions they've they've in this poll
where it's like
the pacific region the heartland the
south the northeast there was a great
book by joel guru
like 30 years ago called the nine
nations of north america
on this topic but i think the north east
might be the most at risk you know look
i can look at the heartland
there's a lot of corn there i can look
at the pacific and be like california
produces a ton of food
i look at look at the south and i'm like
also lots of farmland and fertile areas
mountains impossible to take
north how would you invade them what is
what does the northeast have
the northeast has ports i mean if you go
to whole foods in cambridge
massachusetts right now
you know where is that food coming from
i'm sure some of it is coming from
vermont but a lot of it's coming from
chile or but let's let's say the
northeast was just you know
by itself okay what does it have to
offer for its ports to function
lumber crab lumber yeah i mean
you know i i think that where's new
hampshire can i get what do we expect
we've got a lot of rocks
new hampshire i think it's leading
industries are things like you know
healthcare administration and uh you
know well you know
i don't want to work in that industry
i'd rather do what i do um
but again this gets to the red tribe
belief that like that's not real work
it's all make work and there's no reason
for it to exist
and uh i'm gonna go with sort of a
chesterton fence that you know
this exists and i assume there's a good
reason for it they're presumably
delivering value to someone
there are many jobs that should not
exist but are forced to
there's a great essay [ __ ] excuse me
uh but but bold jobs and i don't like
and i think i
uh do agree with that so so i'm not
going to contradict myself
i thought about this for a long time
insurance salesmen no offense if you
sell insurance
but you know most for the most part
people go online and automatically
get their service mcdonald's fast food
restaurants
they just reply some people with kiosks
and so what i think
is happening is that one thing i've
actually i've talked about this
for for since i was a teenager the
the um the struggle of capitalism in a
technology technological revolution is
uh
and this is a really obvious for a lot
of people where that when you bring
when you have an industrialization a lot
of jobs get washed away
but in our current system we don't just
give people stuff the challenge there is
if one person has to work to to help the
society survive
they will not tolerate for them very
likely if other people are not working
and getting equal access to resources
right so so
so long as there are people who need to
make food
giving free food to other people is
going to make people angry
in which case that's one of the biggest
challenges we have
as we move forward technologically
you'll get people saying don't take my
job away
and then when someone gets their job
taken away through no fault of their own
and then you get a government subsidy
then they're like you're taking my tax
dollars to pay them
with this potential breakup or great
reset they will erase
all of these jobs and they are we see
fast food restaurants struggling to hire
people
how long until they all just upgrade to
kiosks many of them probably will and
then and then how about this i went to i
was at i was at a a rest station
did an ice cream ice cream box and it
was a little robot man
and i put i wanted a chocolate sundae
with with chocolate syrup and sprinkles
and the little robot man just goes and
then hands me the little thing
we don't need a human being to do it
anymore so this great reset
i imagine is going to purge a ton of
jobs
to go off on a tangent about this job
loss um you know the
the libertarian or free market answer is
you know actually
automation and steel mills is great
because it used to take 100 blacksmiths
to do something and you're sure you're
upset that 99 of them are unemployed
but they're now going to get new jobs as
machinists and you know as we get rid of
the sort of
but that's that's not true somebody
somebody who is mining coal can't learn
to code
right and and so i agree with you and
that's where i'm going with this thesis
it was true to some decent degree that
as certain jobs went away there were
always more jobs that were brought in
but we're getting to a point where we
can automate any job that requires less
than a 70 iq and then an 80 iq and a 90
iq
and you know someone who happens to be
born with a 90 iq that's no deficit of
character that's just how it is and he's
equally human being as anyone
else but you start to get to a problem
when we can automate anything under
a 90 or 95 or 100 or 105 iq and i do
worry that we're getting to that world
now you were talking about the
anger against welfare and there is a
fair bit of anger but on the other hand
we have as a society a rhetorical device
or several rhetorical devices
we have welfare for the old called
social security and the polite fiction
is you paid into that and you did
but you end up taking a lot more out of
it than you put in and we have another
plate fiction which is disability and
the the
fiction there is you can't work so a
decent society helps you and there are
some people who are truly disabled uh
there was a good article in the atlantic
i don't know like two or three years ago
talking about how disability is kind of
a different form of welfare
where if you go to the right doctor and
say the right things where there are um
unfalsifiable statements like my back
hurts then you get it
and um so you know all societies have
white lies they tell themselves and i
wonder if disability is ours to deal
with the fact that cognitive
but look things are being praised now
let's let's think about that in term in
the context of
the great reset or or a great divorce
within this country
how how will people in cities get access
to food from
uh farmers if right now what we're
seeing is they're doing this
unemployment thing they've been doing it
non-stop they're doing child tax credits
now
so a lot of people who aren't working
are getting money that means
for the farmer who's growing corn or
wheat or whatever and they go to sell it
they do a lot of work they have to you
can't just snap your fingers and make
that stuff it's
right it's not that's hard work but you
don't just poke a hole in the ground and
drop a seed and it was like como or
something right the people in the cities
they're handed money and they walk to
you and they get your labor
effectively for free right how that i
can't imagine that's sustainable yeah
the only way that actually keeps
sustaining itself is that the people
doing the work don't
know that people who aren't doing work
are you know
as long as they don't know that's
happening but they do know what's
happening yeah yeah so i can only
imagine
you know going back to that as you
mentioned the the what do you call it a
red state belief or the
yeah red state red tribe red dry belief
um
i'll tell you this man i know a lot of
people live in cities
you put them in the middle of the woods
it's over so this ties into a prepping
thing
where um you know i sometimes flip
through prepping magazines when i'm at
the bookstore having a coffee which i do
you know once a week or so
um or you know someone will afford me
something off of a prepping form and
people
like this idea that oh i'm gonna buy a
can of survival seeds or
my plan when the system collapses i'm
going to bug out and i'm going to find
an abandoned farm and i'll just start
farming and um you know speaking of my
own experience
my wife and i have been on the farm for
about eight years and we have been
working you know hugely hard you know
on the order of you know all of saturday
all of sunday weeding and chainsawing
down trees and converting pasture and
stretching fences and we've also brought
in pros to help us with some of this
like you know fencing and other stuff
and there's so much equipment and
there's so much specialized knowledge
which is why the books are so thick
where you know i learned that you know
oh in this pasture i want to grow
hay so that i can feed sheep so i can
get food from that but before i can grow
hay i've got to kill off the poison ivy
which means that i need to put down 2 4
d and 360 at a certain application rate
we we just to finish real quickly the
idea that you're going to wander out
with a can of survival seeds
as civilization is collapsing and you
know feed yourself is
absolutely insane homesteading is a
viable approach but you know it's a
10-year plan what what's
the uh um for uh what's tomatoes
how long out of the year do you get
viable
right absolutely so uh you know if you
plant
all of your tomatoes at once all of your
tomato harvest is going to come in over
a course of two weeks now you can
stagger that by planting tomatoes
week one week two week three in
different batches but even then
your tomatoes are going to be very you
know short interval and there's not a
lot of calories in tomatoes
so uh you know again getting the
survival scenario this is fine you know
homesteading is a hobby and a lifestyle
and i'll defend it as that but it's not
um you know a way to survive the
apocalypse with no inputs there's a huge
amount of inputs of diesel fuel and
fertilizer and other stuff oh yeah yeah
we
uh we have uh our tomatoes i would say
that
we had four uh um
standard tomato plants and one cherry
tomato the cherry tomatoes
easy i walk outside we pick them all we
walk in they're good to go
the regular tomatoes are extremely
difficult the bugs get them yep
the uh they they a lot of rot some of
them turn black you know and there's all
sorts of details like if you want to
save the seeds from tomatoes tomatoes
are
uh tricky because there is a sort of gel
like coating on the seeds and you have
to let the seeds sit in the gel and rot
for a week or two and then wash them off
and then preserve the seeds
and this is another thing that uh you
know if you don't know this stuff you're
just gonna make an
absolute hash of it yeah yeah so um
you know we have a garden and the funny
thing is we get like baseball bat size
zucchini
and over the course of the past two
weeks it's like we can't eat all this
like we just said we set up a garden but
we grew a whole bunch
all the all the tomatoes come around the
same time yep and then we're like what
are we gonna do
right make a sauce i guess you know
preservation technology is huge and
there's a whole
lot of flavors that we as humans like
because we sort of evolved
in a semi-civilized state we love smoked
beef jerky
because that's a preservation technology
we like pickles because that's a
preservation technology we're like
cheese because that's a preservation
technology
um and my hint with the zucchini by the
way um i peel my zucchini i shred them
in a food processor i vacuum seal them i
throw in a chest freezer
and then i mix that with ground turkey
and onions and make turkey fritters all
year long
now what's fascinating though is that a
lot of what you're describing is we got
modern technology like freezers and
refrigerators
so i'll tell you this man where we are
right now
we are um this this facility is going to
be
for the most part off the grid nice
meaning our water is well water
and we're getting solar and batteries
installed nice we're still on the grid
yep
but in the event of an absolute
catastrophe we're going to be able to be
fine we'll have to reduce a lot of our
energy consumption
but uh actually we'll have a decent
amount of power these batteries are
hefty men yup i i i carried like four
thousand pounds of lead acid batteries
down in my basement
without my system so i know all about it
yeah they are nifty well
well i think we're gonna have lithium
nice i'm not entirely sure i put mine in
around seven or eight years ago and i'm
going to
i'm building up the solar right now and
the second battery bank is going to be
lithium but but let's let's be real man
like
people in cities stacked on top of each
other they're they're not going to have
any of this
power is going to go out and the food's
going to be gone i was i was in new york
when sandy
hit mm-hmm and there were there were two
guys staying outside of a bodega with
like a two with two by fours and a
baseball bat
one person at a time and the guy said
all the refrigerator stuff is spoiled
because the power was out for a couple
weeks right right they were like the
cans are good everything else is spoiled
so you know take what you want korean's
awesome yeah mountain dew was fine
you know all the sodas were fine but uh
um anything perishable
gone right so your freezers all that
stuff in the city yeah over
right and um what are those people going
to do yeah
no they they are absolutely screwed and
you're going to find them on your farm
well uh you know i do have a chapter on
firearms
well there you go right um you know
this ties back to the idea of prepping
in the power law which is the title of
one of the essays i think it's in volume
two
where uh you know how often does new
york city
lose power um you know for a week or
something it happened i think back in 76
or 78 or something
yeah and hurricane sandy so this is the
kind of thing it seems inconceivable
but you pull back and zoom out and
you're like no this crap happens every
30 or 40 years and you're going to live
another 30 or 40 years you're going to
see it happen again you're going to see
all these things happening in your
lifetime
this is the craziest thing to me about
when i was like last year i'm like hey
guys pick up these you know food bins
yeah i i got to say it was mostly these
young people a lot of these lefties
these socialists are young
they don't have the worldly experience
to have dealt with these things
having seen hurricane sandy yeah i was
like wow it would be great if i had one
of those food bins
so i remember when i was living in new
york and there i can't remember what was
happening there was some concern about
another storm i went and bought
i bought two things of bottled water i
was like that's going to be important
they tell you in chicago whenever they
say there's a big storm coming you fill
up your bathtub yeah
because you know if the water goes bad
if lines break if some disaster happens
you got a bunch of water in your bathtub
that's the kind of thing people who are
older i guess
learn younger people don't but still
there is like
this arrogance of of many people live in
cities like you said they think they can
grab
a can of seeds and go find a farm
somewhere right i'll tell you man
in the uh what did what did noam chomsky
say in the arena of violence the most
brutal guy wins and that ain't us and he
was referring to leftists
right right these people think they're
going to go to a farm where they're
going to find a guy who's been
using a gun a firearm or multiple ones
for practical purposes be it hunting or
you know or
or you know dealing with rodents and
stuff and they're going to be able to
walk on and just
lay claim right to a already built up
and secured and maintained farm
fertilizer yeah that's what they're
going to be as fertilizers right
you know i don't know if humans can be
fertilizer that's kind of i don't know
i've got a chapter of composting
well we hope it doesn't come to that
honestly right right uh a lot of hungry
people though
you know so there's another thing that i
hear in prepping circles uh and it's a
feel-good phrase
you know it's not the equipment that you
have that matters it's what you know
that matters because you know
equipment can be taken from you but what
you know is a resource yeah
and you know if if there's some guy
living in a basement uh you know
in brooklyn and he's been reading
survival forms for six years and then
the system collapses and he comes out to
my farm and wants to share his knowledge
with me for food
you know i don't need any knowledge that
this guy you know learned from endlessly
recycled blog posts
um you know there's oh gosh uh
there's some ancient greek words for
different kinds of knowledge techni and
medicine or something
but to really really know something
you've got to do it you've got to do it
ahead of time and you're absolutely
doing this with your tomatoes and your
chicken so if you lost power
you've already practiced it so that's
real knowledge it's not something you
just you want
you want we got it we got a couple
mulberry trees mm-hmm and so we made
mulberry jam
we made we mixed wine berry and mulberry
like a wild baby that was actually
really i'm not a big fan of mulberries
oh i love them but but when you mix some
when i mix them with the wine berries is
really good
and the wine berries alone i think the
combination but anyway digress
do you know many calories you probably
do are in 10 mulberries uh i'm guessing
that it rounds to zero
like ten six okay all right six yeah ian
nailed it last time
he's like six i'm like how did you know
that but ten
wow that's a small handful of berries
you're gonna shove in your mouth
six calories right you will not there's
there's no amount of mulberry you're
gonna eat to sustain yourself
for even a few hours right and so you
know naturally occurring fruits and
stuff people don't realize
uh i'll tell you this story and this
this place i do exactly what i'm saying
i had friends during occupy wall street
got granted farmland mm-hmm
how long do you think let me ask you how
long do you think they last that they
made it
so so they went out there and tried to
say they said they said
we we don't want to be on the grid we're
tired of contributing to this this this
machine of pollution and climate change
so we're going to the farm to live
sustainably
three days a week two weeks okay weeks
you know i'm impressed most people say
like a couple months no
no a few days you didn't even give them
better than that uh two weeks
okay you know what they realized i asked
my friend she was like
i was like why'd you come back she was
like because i'd wake up at six a.m to
work go to bed at
midnight and i'm like yeah what did you
think farming was
when you were actually trying to sustain
yourself you
never stop working right right and and
this gets into
you know people have said you know to me
oh you know if we had a collapse of it
you'd love it you know
like no man uh right now it's a very
very hard hobby that i do on the
weekends
with lots of diesel fuel coming in
outside
if that diesel fuel went away and you
know i tried to make a producer gas
still using old fema plans and started
logging trees
to make producer gas to do stuff you
know that
is better than starving to death but uh
that's hard but you know what i did this
morning
i went out and i grabbed some fresh
jalapenos
and a poblano and some some cherry
tomatoes
and then i i went to the chicken coop
and i got a couple eggs and so uh one of
our chickens is i guess she's young so
she's doing double eggs like they're
twice as big they're messy right and uh
i would say
to be fair 99 of my breakfast was
completely
home-grown yeah but i threw in some
garlic powder and and people like to say
you know and it's so much healthier i'm
not sure it is healthier but man it's so
much more satisfying isn't it that's
just amazing we're like this all came
from me you know to be honest
um i'm not a big fan of like throwing
peppers
like if i went to a restaurant i ordered
i'd be like give me the bacon and the
eggs with
your cheese on top but today i had
cherry tomatoes with
fresh cut jalapenos poblano on eggs and
it tasted so good
nice nice you know that is one of the
most satisfying things and we've done
all sorts of stuff um you know we've
made
corn fritters we've uh made
maple uh syrup creme brulee from maple
trees that we've tapped and i boil down
the sap and make my own maple syrup
um i i i push back on homesteaders who
say everything tastes better like no you
know some food at you know whole foods
in the supermarket it tastes really good
the one thing that uh comes from the
farm that's just absolutely amazing is
homemade bacon
and you know i'm not gonna say it's ten
percent better it's 20 better homemade
bacon is like literally ten times better
like you just don't want store made
stuff
we've got farms around here and so we we
have gotten fresh and it is
indescribable yeah
right like i i don't even want the
store-bought stuff right right i mean
it's not the same yeah
it's a pale imitation it's like turkey
bacon or something it's like turkey
bacon
and if i can plug my own book again oh
yeah i've got tons of details on how to
make your own bacon from scratch and you
can do it even living on the suburbs i
started this
is it is it does it is it just take pig
it does yeah i mean the ingredients say
you know uh you need you know
salt salt man um and you need uh and you
need pig and you know for pig
see page 458 um but
uh you can practice a bunch of the stuff
living in the suburbs you can buy a
whole pork belly from the butcher and do
it
do you think people who live in cities
should escape the cities right now
um you know so one of the things i've
got in the intro chapter
is you know here's a three-year here's a
one-year plan you're you're ready to
move what do you need to do
here's a three-year plan and one of the
things i have is a 10-year plan for
young adults because i've had a lot of
you know friends on twitter who are 22
or 26
ask me and you know i've said on the
10-year plan don't move
right this second you know the cities
aren't about to collapse tomorrow what
you need to do
is uh learn a skill you need to learn
some stuff and you need to find your
mate um it's a lot easier to meet people
in the city than it is out in the middle
of nowhere
so you don't think i i think people
should be getting away from cities
immediately okay well
that's gonna help me sell the book uh so
i agree tim i've never heard an idea
that's so right
with you know you look at how the the
law is being enforced um
it's been referred to uh i know mike
mike cernovich tweeted about this i
think
um maybe michael mals may have mentioned
it anarcho tyranny absolutely and those
are two good followers i followed with
these guys as well
for those aren't familiar tyranny is
basically that the government doesn't
enforce the crimes and petty things that
are negatively impacting your life
you're being robbed
but they do enforce anything that uh
goes against them in any way
or the powerful elites yeah so
absolutely arson during riots well
that's just a bit of vibrant democracy
you know that that went you know two
percent too far but on the other hand
you know some
white-collar guy has a pistol that you
know isn't known to the attorney general
to have all 17 of the checkpoints and
you know he gets dragged through the
system and he's lucky if he you know
gets off with that jail
time after he spent a hundred thousand
dollars on legal fees i see this i see
this as being you know for the most part
where we are
i mentioned that you know joe biden
clearly isn't speaking to half the
country
and that's a failure on his part i mean
you look at what uh jen sackey issued
one of the most shocking statements
when she said that they were working
with facebook oh my gosh it's horrifying
when when the
administration is now admitting that
they're working with the dnc to go to
phone carriers to censor private text
messages
it is it is beyond it it is our anarcho
tyranny they're riots in the streets
that the crime is skyrocketing the
police are being defunded yet the
government is coming after
private citizens to an extreme degree
there was a great quote
uh i think it was from p.j o'rourke i
read it 10 or 20 years ago
which is that petta goes after
women wearing fur coats and not bikers
wearing leather jackets
part of the explanation behind a narco
tyranny you know i mentioned earlier
that i studied uh roman history
and one thing in the later days of the
empire the
uh roman political elite wanted triumphs
which was a big parade through downtown
rome because it looked great and have
treasure
and the problem is that to conquer a
tough
foreign tribe is hard and there's not
many of them they're far away so
at some point the roman political elites
started waging war against allies and
their own provinces
um because it was a way to you know kill
a bunch of people and take some treasure
yeah
um and so this ties into a narco tyranny
who's easier to prosecute sort of you
know some uh you know
high ranking uh you know corruption or
just pick a random white color guy you
know you know i'm just
i'm at this point sick of people who are
the frog in the pot boiling who refuse
to accept what is happening around them
because i've had so many conversations
where i'm like listen
you know i'm not trying to be a
doomsayer
i am not absolutely predicting what will
happen i'm only
simply asking if everything we've seen
over the past 10 years has been
escalating
do you think it is more likely that the
escalation will continue or
that right now the escalation will stop
and things will improve right that's a
great way to frame it but that's um
so i'm not saying i mean quite literally
tomorrow joe biden
could come out and say i want to issue a
heartfelt sincere apology to all of
trump's supporters for everything that's
happened in this country and i want to
know that i am here for you and i'm
going to be sitting down
and you know he could he could say
something he won't right what does he
say
he says the republicans voting bills is
the greatest threat since the civil war
they no one no one is backing down and
no one will stop
this gets into the rhetoric where nazi
and racist are the ultimate trump cards
uh you know the civil war so this is
implicitly putting
anyone who doesn't agree with you know
sort of every policy of the democratic
party is obviously on the side of
bringing back slavery
civil war he's saying it at a time when
when we have
this poll coming out whether the polls
accurate or not and the sentiment is
rising for for a breakup of this country
i can only say that a president who
would say that is encouraging
and he's an accelerationist yep he wants
to happen now i can say this over and
over again
i do not want anything bad to happen to
this country and i think the divide is
horrifying because of what
will happen with our enemies the last
thing i want is for china to take taiwan
now no
no chips for computers and cars and
china controls that
they gain more control in all of these
other regions as they are expanding with
the mountain road initiative
we need a strong united america joe
biden i think is doing everything to rip
it apart
you know um there's an essay i read once
uh
i think was by this guy clark hat um on
status 451 blog talking about the
machinery of state and state machines
and the idea is that
there are things that can roll forward
but that can't roll back the same way
and you can see it in mechanical
engineering with worm gears and
everything
and i'm not sure what the output of this
is i mean accelerationism and the
collapse of the united states
uh sounds terrible but if we were in the
kind of system where we could back up
we would have already backed up so i
don't know how we get out i
i've talked to so many people um and i
mentioned this
frequently particularly in the past week
or so with this poll that came out
talk of the city's trap the mit study
that came you saw the mit thing i did
not
1972 mit said was it mit i was mit right
by 2040 society will collapse due to
these factors and everything like that
i'm like
i'm looking at all these things i'm
looking at a vice president who's
saying this is the biggest threat since
the civil war and he said the
confederates never made it to the
capitol and i'm like wow
dude you're saying these these trump
supporters there were hundreds of
thousands of people who didn't go in the
capital
you're likening trump's base to the
confederates
how could that not be accelerationism
but i see this i've seen
so many people over the past several
years tell me i was wrong or crazy to
think that we're headed towards some
kind of civil conflict
and i'm like bro we're in it yeah we are
in it and and
you know how could we have come to this
point i had a conversation recently with
someone who's like nah
nah everything's gonna be fine it's
gonna calm down we're all going to go
back to normal and i'm like
why because trump's going to decide not
to run because trump's going to just
disappear overnight
or do you think 2022 trump's going to be
doing the circuit promoting people in
the midterms the media is going to find
their path towards making money again
and so that doesn't matter what's true
or not they're going to go they're
absolutely insane rile people up to an
extreme degree
and then we're gonna have three years of
that and you think it's gonna be all
fine you know i think
so i'm agreeing with your overall thesis
but i think even if trump dropped
dead from a heart attack tomorrow the
two tribes have been
led to hate each other so much and this
is you know uh fuel
uh the media loves it uh the democrats
love it um
and because it gets excitement it gets
people out to the polls it gets
donations the new york times loves it i
mean the new york times has been hugely
more profitable over the last few years
than it ever was before
um and so the aclu is the perfect
example oh god you know
they used to be wonderful i mean i i
lean more to the right than to the left
but i always loved the aclu is man they
stick by their principles and even i who
disagree with
most of the members of it on free speech
they rock but what happened was
they made a bunch of money when they
challenged donald trump's moratorium on
travel from those seven countries
and then they got a bunch of flack over
charlottesville
and so they immediately said money is
more important than values
yep and we've seen that with many
different organizations
i mean there used to be a concept of
academic freedom where okay uh
this one professor with his crazy ideas
you know disagrees with all decent
society
but we respect free speech and free
inquiry so much that we will support him
in this
and you know that was a useful tool
until the left could entirely finish
their long march through the
institutions
but now that they've got it there's no
academic freedom at all if you want to
say anything that departs from the party
line by two percent you can get fired
i look at these non-profits um and i
look at the the media and i'm just like
there i don't think there's a point at
which the two different versions of
reality ever meet
so there's a i love calling this
organization freepress.net you ever hear
of them yeah
yeah what do you what do you think
they're supposed to be representing
um from the title uh i would think the
free press now would you be surprised to
find out they were advocating censorship
i would not be surprised exactly what
they've been in 1984 ma'am yep they came
true heavily against alex jones saying
he must be censored and banned and
removed
and i knew people there and i hit him up
and i was like what are you doing
and they were like this is important you
know he spreads lies and i'm like you're
the free press
of course you're gonna defend people who
will say bad things so you have to
there's this current uh push right now
to get rid of misinformation and i'm
reading a book i was reading it on the
airplane about
the uh soviets how they almost invented
the internet they had a couple of
networking um
attempts in the 50s 60s 70s and
they had the whole concept of you know
cybernetics which came from the us
and uh then the soviets were playing
with it and there was one part of
cybernetics and information theory and
claude shannon and everything that
immediately had resonance with them
and that was static or noise in the
system because it fit into their
ideology you could talk about
information on the one hand and
noise on the other and that was chilling
to read this in the book about the
soviet internet attempts of the 1970s
because we're hearing it every day
with oh of course we have free speech
but not for misinformation and like oh
man
and do you see what uh um was it npr
said that the truth
with not proper context is
misinformation wonderful so
what's proper context right framing yep
so when the guardian comes out with an
article that says that the kremlin
seems to have compromise on trump or
according to a document
and then all of these people the
establishment left just read the
headline and don't actually read the
story
they believe that we have the proof that
trump is compromised then you read the
actual story what do they say
it's highly unusual suspect the kremlin
denies it
trump denies it and we haven't confirmed
any of the documents but experts think
it may be real right
okay so none of it's confirmed why did
you publish it but if you read nothing
but the headline
there you go it's proof you know
snopes.com is amazing these days because
uh we'll have a politician say you know
the sun rises in the east
and um you know then snopes will say you
know this is absolutely false without
more context because actually the earth
is rotating and the sun stands still
man well the way i always describe it to
people is that what they'll do is
there there'll be a video of donald
trump doing a backflip off of you know a
balcony and landing perfectly in a
superhero pose
everyone will share the video and it'll
go viral it'll get 10 million views and
every conservative will say wow this
trump is spry you know for a 77 year old
man and then snopes will say
did donald trump do a perfect backflip
off of a balcony and land in a superhero
pose
on sunday right they'll say false then
it'll give you a bunch of
exposition garbage and like on saturday
you know the 15th donald trump was
giving a speech
and then trump's known liars finally
exactly without evidence had made these
claims and finally at the bottom after
five
600 words it'll say while trump did do a
perfect backflip
and he did land in a superhero pose it
was on sunday
uh it was on monday at midnight right
which is not sunday right
right which in eastern time zone is not
sunday yeah exactly that's the game
i've been thinking about how we were
talking earlier about how it's not a
linear we're talking about the
accelerationism
essentially and it's not linear it's
like it's kind of like a j curve right
which makes me think of that it's
the beginning of an amplification wave
that may come back down
so maybe it's not going to keep going
maybe you know every exponential curve
is an s curve
once you get to the end of it and so
what's what causes it to amplify
greater is coherent interference we've
got like all this fake
news saying the same stuff creating this
amplification wave
if we create some sort of d coherent d
coherent interference
uh maybe we can reduce the amplification
and slow
the acceleration it seems plausible um
you know
i tend to i i've gotten sort of
apolitical or post-political or
something over the last couple of years
not because i don't think politics
matters you know this is fascinating
stuff and i love to sit here and analyze
it
um and i love to you know sort of go
back and read old books and see what you
know
uh correlations we can get um but i
think these systems
are huge and by systems i mean sort of
you know i i'm pro free market but
capitalism at this point
is this massive you know sort of
headless monster with seven billion
people in it
and you know capitalism is going to do
what it's going to do it's like
evolution you
you know you get perfect sharks uh you
may or may not want a shark but it
doesn't matter
and you know you get the perfect
facebook you get the perfect uh you know
et cetera
and you get the perfect democratic party
and you get the perfect republican party
so only amount of time look at the
perfect movies
yeah movies have whittled down to the
most common denominator of giant robots
blowing stuff up
yeah it used to be like groundhog day
you know yeah it's gonna be perfect like
you're like
and so my response to this is mostly to
just pull back and disconnect and so
you know i've got my friends i've got
you know uh good old books that i read
um yeah i think this is the d coherent
interference
talking about things that aren't in that
narrative
is creating a de-coherence which is
reducing the amplification
yeah well let's take super chats and see
what the audience has to say if you
haven't already give that like button a
nice little tap subscribe to this
channel leave us a good view on those
podcasts and uh go to timcast.com become
a member
for the members podcast which comes up
around 11 p.m every night
and that's usually where we talk about
the things that youtube bans you for but
we'll see sometimes you're just chilling
fun
let's see what we got all right um i
don't think i can read your name
anna we'll just say anna no one cares
about france or australia
american freedom is dying everything
else is irrelevant well you need to
understand that france and australia
could serve as a canary in the coal mine
france is a nation that is very
rebellious to say the least
and they're also having extremely
draconian laws australia
is you know a british commonwealth not
too dissimilar from the united states in
certain ways but they don't have a bill
of rights so
we can thank our lucky stars when we see
these countries and the bad things that
happen ireland
passed uh vaccine passport stuff
recently so
the bill of rights thank your lucky
stars but i don't know how much longer
it's it's going to keep protecting us
all right let's see oh what's this david
quesada says tony hawk came out of
retirement and you're not a real skater
if you don't talk about it
well um good for tony he is uh one of
the
uh best skateboarders ever simply by
well he's
vert skating for sure his skating street
was always funny because he's like a
he's a vert skater guy
but uh he's a legend i mean he invented
so much of skateboarding
however i think at his current age i
don't see him competing with like g
curry who just did a 1080
for the first time in a competition 12
year old kid
tony hawk's twitter game is pretty good
i like him tony hawk's twitter game
consists of him
not being recognized by people i wonder
what tony hawk is doing right now
this right i do love it where they're
like hey your name's tony he's like yup
like that skateboarder tony hawkins
that's right i love those tweets
absolutely he discovered that he's
famous but no one knows what he looks
like
uh no some people do all right hayden
says travis great to have you
i just bought 40 acres of mountain
forest land and i'm realizing i will
need to clear dozens of 40-foot trees to
build and have a garden
awesome do you have any do you have
advice for starting with totally raw
land 20 miles from town now
real quick i also have uh about an acre
with tons of trees on it
and uh your advice on how to deal with
it uh you know i don't want to sound
too much like a shill but um i've got an
entire chapter on exactly that you start
with a forest and you want pasture there
whatever like 17 steps
and uh the short version is you're gonna
log those trees you're probably gonna
have an excavator
come in to pull out the stumps then
you're going to do soil test you're
going to amend the soil as necessary
and there's a lot more but it's
absolutely doable but that's not doable
by
by welfare i mean for the most part
we're talking about
modern technology in a functioning
economy yeah to make this
so you know the way that this was
classically done in colonial america is
that you
would um debark the trees and then they
would die and then you could farm
uh in between them um and you could even
log as you got time you know people tend
to log in the winter that's when i do my
logging
because it's a lot easier to skid the
logs out to my firewood pile using my
tractor on top of snow because it you
know sort of lubricates and also
protects it's easier to see
right yeah yeah and you don't have to
deal with all of the leaves on the trees
uh so you know you can do this all at
once by you know throwing a lot of money
at it or you can make it a 10-year
project
and uh there's tons of good firewood
there there's a rule of thumb that you
can pull
one quart of firewood out of one acre of
forest per year sustainably forever um
and so there's that but also if you want
to log it all at once there's a huge
amount of firewood there you can also
call in a lager
uh he might do it for you but he might
want two-thirds of three-quarters of the
wood
and that's all covered it's a huge topic
and it's fascinating i love talking
about forestry and logging and i love
doing it
cool cool jm says hey ian i was just
thinking about the time i was in a
drug-induced coma
i'm pretty sure i saw interdimensional
beings what do you think
totally possible you ever take
psychedelics i have been fascinated i
never have but man i'd like to meet the
machine elves someday
yeah all right rolla koala says down
with communism
we as a nation need less screen time and
more community service guarantees
citizenship
oh ian down with the fed i i i
we need more community you know jon
stewart said it and i and the reason i
cite jon stewart is because
that should be a message to the left he
come on you like this guy right
well he was like he actually said we
needed a draft of some sort
i i've got a problem with that um you
know i i think that people confuse
uh sort of good things that come from
terrible things with an overall
benefit from it so you know you get
drafted for a very good cause which is
you know
uh fascism is terrible and putting
people in death camps is terrible
and then you make a lot of you know
lifelong buddies and whatever
um but right now most of the wars we're
fighting are absolutely idiotic and it's
always uh people who wouldn't be subject
to the draft who think that other people
need to be drafted
but he wasn't i don't believe in slavery
saying military draft yeah he was saying
some kind of community
like i don't want to be drafted to be a
social worker and i wouldn't want anyone
else to be drafted for it either
there there is you know i thought about
this um the challenge is that you end up
with a bunch of entitled people
and there's there's a balance it's not
so simple i guess um the
the the libertarian aspect of it is
leave me alone let me do my thing which
is where i
usually land on you know when it comes
to the dividing line but i also
recognize that
without a shared community space is what
i was saying i do agree with this yeah
if people are online and like you know
i'm talking only to
you know more libertarian types but then
my neighbors talking to socialists
conflicts are brilliant because we live
next to each other yeah so there's got
to be some kind of you know
i i i do agree that shared culture is
good um i also
think that shared experiences coming out
of voluntary behavior are much better
and one final thing on this idea of some
sort of civil draft
think about all the programs and the way
they're actually run no matter how great
the theory is the schools the dmv
uh think about how it's actually
implemented and so if we had some sort
of social draft
you know that uh the children of the
rich and wealthy would end up
being drafted to work in policy think
tanks in dc with wonderful apartments
and you know that the children of coal
miners would be picking up garbage on
the
side of the road captain says i have a
cabin in northern az and want to
homestead there permanently but i work
in i.t and need internet
i have been on the starlink waiting list
for over a year now
i believe the starling starlink is
moving from the east coast towards the
west coast i could be wrong it's just
because i know
i met somebody who has got uh new york
starlink
and they said that this area is going to
get it
near the uh at late august late uh 2021
i they said
so i think they're activating satellite
groups you know moving
in a direction but uh i don't know for
sure i will tell you starlink's amazing
absolutely when when it activates it
works within a 500 mile radius so my
understanding is
they want you to keep it in the same
place but as long as you're within that
range
so we could we could drive like you know
half an hour up the top of a mountain
yeah
and you know that that's all sort of
policy because the satellites are
continuously orbiting paths so you're
getting handed off you know time and
again
right um you know i i think that
starlink uh is accelerating in its
deployment so
uh i think wait a little bit longer but
uh that's great
all right seth says if you ever wondered
why there's dumb failure politicians in
office
it's because these people are highly
sought after for government because they
will say or do
whatever they're told no matter how
absurd yeah this gets back to evolution
i mean you know they are
uh we breed politicians according to
selection criteria and the selection
criteria is electability
and uh you know when everyone has the
franchise uh that means that the median
voter is pretty dumb and pretty
uninformed
all right let's see hulk mash says hey
guys
excuse me first of all this is my
favorite podcast out there well thank
you very much
also i use clips of the show for my tick
tock and one of the videos got over a
million views if you ever want to back
up tick tock it's all yours oh wow cool
um our tic toc got briefly taken down
no idea why they just deleted all the
videos and i laughed i'm like whatever
man
and then um i tweeted about it and then
it popped right back up
but i'm proud to say that um timcast.com
we are officially self-sustainable there
was a big fear for a while that like you
know we're beholden to
all these different platforms and then
if we got banned oh no it's like we
can't work what do we do so i was like
we got to start a website
we started a website and now the new
website is up we've got a news crew
everything that's currently happening
with our news writers and our new show
and our current level
is sustainable just off of the website
alone that's amazing so
the youtube all the stuff we're doing
out is is like our path towards rapid
expansion
so uh daily wire can sit there and get
smear pieces from npr because they're
expanding so rapidly
don't worry daily wire we're coming for
you we're going to be expanding i know
much congratulations on the success of
that npr's smear piece yeah i know it's
going to be great
but uh you all know you've made we're we
were just uh um talking with a
particular individual
um about doing field reporting and
journalism i'll refrain from saying who
i guess but people
might already know and uh we're going to
be launching a bunch of different shows
like cultural shows
so um i'm extremely uh excited for this
tic toc and banis i don't even care
anymore i'm just like whatever dude yeah
eric cecil says kyle kashuv is david
hogg driving the speed limit
okay i'm not i think there needs more
give me more context there to understand
what kyle did
you know but uh i think you know i've
been saying this for a long time
the right needs to be advocating for
like guaranteed gun access you know i'm
a bit i'm a big fan of the idea that uh
universal gun ownership like the
government should be should have to pay
for people's
people to have a gun yes yeah everybody
yeah and you know the argument is so
long as you know these left says that
health care is a human right
and that the government should provide
everyone with health care i'm like hey
hey hold on
i got i'm down i'm down but i think then
everybody should have to get a gun from
the government you know the right has
been sort of overly libertarian in a
certain way where the left uses the
machinery of the state to
indoctrinate and sort of set the playing
field and i think that one thing that
trump has started and that other
republicans are seeing is hey
if we manage to grab the reins of power
for two or four or six years
we shouldn't just you know pause the
expansion of the state and pause the
success of the cultural war from one
side we could do something with it
and it's going to be really interesting
to see that play out you know what's
crazy is that there are reigns of power
at all
i i mean maybe is that in the inevitable
superstructure of the universe
of power do they have to be meritocracy
exists whether whether the the
communists want to believe it or not it
is a real thing
but so look look during occupy wall
street they kept saying we have no
leaders
and i was like they're standing right
there i can see them they're the ones
talking to the camera
but they're not really leaders yes but
whatever they say you do
you can say they're not formally leaders
but they're clearly the ones who control
all the money
who determine when you march who
determine when the meetings happen and
shut down people they
don't want to speak i guess the problem
of meritocracy being real is who holds
the reins of power isn't necessarily the
one with the merit
well no no um i i disagree to a certain
to a certain extent
i mean certainly we can argue that a
great leader who's very smart and
capable would be the one with the true
merit
but in terms of wielding power as the
person capable of wielding it
so it's kind of like you said there's a
giant rock who can lift the giant rock
the person capable of picking it up and
carrying it or who gets there first
well no not not really who deceives all
the others about where the rock is
well look look could could could you
uh if if you were um if there's a giant
rock
you know let's say let's let's the atlas
stone we have what does that weigh 160
yeah you have an atlas stone
the rock dwayne johnson gave you a
10-minute head start
do you think you'd be able to lift the
atlas stone before him no
he'd show up push you step aside sir and
then he'd pick it up very easily
there are some people that are built to
carry rocks there are some people who
are brilliant
how leadership works too when you look
at like occupy wall street
it was necessarily there was a power
vacuum there was a bunch of people there
there was a bunch of interest in funding
it and there was a vacuum in who
controlled it until someone said
i will and everyone went okay and then
that person
took it so they're saying they wanted it
there's an interesting thing here that
whoever takes it that's sort of the
metric that is uh
being tested for you know whoever
successfully pulls the sword out of the
stone
or whoever successfully rises to the
front of the crowd and occupy
and the mistake the founders make was
thinking that
whoever could win elections was the best
leader or
most appealed to the populace and in a
sense they're right it most appealed to
the populace
but it's a simple test there's some rule
of thumb and i forget what it is
but whenever you have a metric that's
being tested in a organization or in a
industrial process uh it works for you
know a minute and then pretty soon it
gets subverted because people start
optimizing for the test
and not for the true underlying thing
which you were approximating with the
test and i think that's true of
democracy
all right atari kid says slavery in the
british empire ended in 1833 but slavery
in england ceased after the norman
conquest
the somerset case of 1772 ruled that
slavery was so odious that nothing can
be suffered to support it but positive
law
interesting i've got one piece of uh
tangential thing there which i touch on
the norman conquest in my homesteading
books
in the context of how deeds work for
tractors ah
interesting interesting jr says you can
burn plant matter to make potassium
chloride
it's a salt substitute can also harvest
it from animal blood
oh really whoa yeah i guess they gotta
have salt in them
so i guess you can get salt from deer
blood huh uh true um i
make uh uh black pudding from pig blood
and it's salty
blood pudding is that blood pudding yeah
it's good yeah i love blood pudding
the first time i had i was on is in the
uk and you get like a black disc
yep yep and then i'm like what's that
and they're like blood pudding i'm like
cool i know a lot of people who hate it
but i'm like food's food
that's decent yeah yeah yeah all right
seb says hi from sweden first time
catching the show live for obvious
reasons been subbed since the van videos
wow that was like the first video
yeah excellent man wrong time what up
dude all right let's see
scary parody says officially closed on
our florida home today here's 10 bucks
to celebrate can't wait to be living
there
goodbye seattle oh talk about an epic
move
congrats from seattle ugh to florida hey
now my only issue with florida is the
weather but the governance
it's not bad that's my only reason uh
issue with texas i'd be there if it
weren't for the heat
oh man luke keeps trying to get us to go
to new hampshire
and he did even even before we came out
here was like new hampshire's way better
and i was like dude
i don't want to be in new hampshire it's
expensive there's you know there's not
as much land it's way more expensive i'm
like i'll be in the middle of nowhere in
the middle mountains
plus like you know new hampshire's
surrounded by all these blue areas there
is that
yeah very very heavily just every
direction but you've got water access
yep yep
got a river if if the country partitions
in new hampshire is taken over by
massachusetts then i'll be a refugee
all right we got a nice big super chat
from trd sc
fjc fjc about not liking black rifle
coffee company
um youtube's not gonna allow me to read
that super chat
suffice it to say they're very upset
with black rifle coffee as am i
saying that they don't support patriots
who defend themselves
against uh um bad child abusers felons
and domestic abusers
they say free kyle salty army is legion
the salt must flow and re
yeah i saw a lot of bad stuff about
black rifle yeah because they're
basically lumping in
like the majority of the right in with
the most extreme elements
absolutely tweeting about even earlier a
month or so ago i saw that i think their
ceo had donated to a pro-gun control
politician who said no one needs an
ar-15
so you know black rifle is an
interesting marketing scheme but
i'm not sending them my money well they
were able to get a bunch of money from a
lot of conservatives
all right let's see anime freak says you
guys mentioned a few videos back text
censorship
i work in one of the highest departments
you can work in within one of the major
carriers and i can say
if a law was made we likely wouldn't bet
an eye implementing it
interesting well the intention of the
government is is is very scary
john clapperton says no native of india
or any natural born subject of his
majesty shall be
shall be disabled from holding any place
office or employment for any reason
employment by reason of his religion
place of birth d descent
or or color charter of the east india
company
interesting very interesting all right
let's see
uh i see and i saw super chat defending
alex jones okay
all right let's see what we got people
and making fun of uh china yeah
absolutely all right
el uh uh less seri lesseri
i've been doing research on helpful
weeds for example large leafed plantain
that draws out venom
and can be used as a flower substitute
just to name two uses
i'll uh it'll leave you speechless like
the book by michael knowles that's out
now
that one got me that genuinely got me
yeah normally i'm catching the
speechless ones but that one got me
um yeah in terms of like like wheat
flour right it's got gluten is there
anything else that you could use that's
like
comparable um you know uh there are
other flowers
i know that people use acorn flour i
think that the gluten in
wheat flour is hard to replace and i
know that rye etc just doesn't
rise in the same way because you don't
get the intermittent gluten
yeah all right let's see will jones says
timmy is controlled opposition
who else can guarantee a business
success well played comrade well played
we like reading our criticism here at
tim castrol for sure
that is silly sandra nadeau says sorry
divorce will not work i'm not moving
nor will i give up my rights i will
stand my ground
yeah i hear that you know we have we
have conversations about places like
syria where so many people refuse to
stay and fight and they fled
and i actually interviewed two young men
who refused to fight and fled
and so i mean can you blame him you know
be forced to fight for
for this this national army and have
your right shipped away and just be
cannon fodder or
and and or leave and watch your your
home country fall apart
not easy man all right garhant says
travis with you writing for dragon
117 are you buying the new dnd
stricthaven book
if so are you excited to get your bestie
frenemy and who's your prom date for d d
prom
i am auro rolf limau
ralph hasbro they are so kathleen
kennedy for wokeness
okay you play dnd uh i i did play back
uh dnd
uh there's some backstory there which is
my uh you know i'm a writer and my first
published uh thing was when i was 13
years old and sent an article
into dragon magazine and that was
published in dragon issue 117
and about 20 years later i saw in
passing that
tsr which had been bought by wizards of
the coast which had been bought by
hasbro
was republishing um all of the old
articles
and i happened to remember reading my
contract from start to finish
and the contract said that i was selling
first serial rights
which meant that if they ever wanted to
republish it they had to pay me so i
sent a letter to hasbro
and said i'm thrilled to hear about this
cd-rom pay me
um and hasbro never responded the letter
they republished the cd-rom
and i sued hasbro in small claims court
for two thousand dollars because that
was the most i could sue for
and hasbro didn't show and i got two
thousand dollars so that's how as a
thirteen year old i earned two thousand
one hundred dollars i just had to wait
20 years to get creativity
well then and with regards to uh ttrpgs
uh
i live in the middle of nowhere i try to
play occasionally online with some
friends i hope to do more of that
um i do buy books it's it's fun to just
see what's going on and
the crazy insanity sjw stuff in uh d and
d
uh there's a new um uh
you know there was some wheelchair thing
because when people do escapism what
they really want to think about is being
disabled
um and then the new thing that was
announced a day or so ago was some sort
of new
woke harry potter bisexual elves in
college campaign setting for d d
and i'm just going to quote the meme of
the chinese guy it's also tiresome yes
wow
all right scott mackinton says insurance
sales is necessary
ensuring your home and auto is easy
mostly can be done through a computer
and automated process
large complex commercial industries
requiring insurance need a human to
underwrite and risk assess
100 agree and i i accept that with the
and i will issue the correction what i
meant to say is there are a lot of
people that used to just do like auto
you'd walk in and be like i want to do
auto and there are still places that do
this
they're store fronts and a guy sitting
behind a desk waiting for you yeah
for me i see that i'm like that's crazy
of course i think they're mostly going
away
but like they're you know they're still
video stores
actually they need them in places with
with bad internet yeah video store still
exists i hear that car
salesmen are on their way out in that
you know tesla will send the car to your
house directly like you go online you
order it online
a lot of companies will do that yeah
there's a lot of stuff that is
basically just rent-seeking like maybe
at some point it started out um but
rent-seeking is an economic term and not
rent as any reasonable thing where
you're trading money for use of land
uh but rent where someone just
interjects themselves in a transaction
and
peels their slice off the top and
there's no way to get around it like a
banker
all right tim decker says march 9th for
the win why that's my birthday is it
your birthday
16-year three-ma 3m mile trucker here
the left has made trucking into cities a
loss leader with fuel costs and
regulations drivers already refuse loads
to the coasts consider that
yeah man you know what i think's
happening you know we were at an ice
cream stand the other day
and there's a huge line and everyone's
buying ice cream and i thought to myself
how many
people got jobs you know because a lot
of people are getting unemployment so
what does that mean
they're being given money and then
they're extracting resources from the
system
without replacing it basically it's kind
of like i was thinking we have a slushy
machine downstairs
you know and um when it's full it's full
of slushy but you got to keep putting
slushy in eventually the slushie runs
out
well what what they're printing slushy
what happens no no they're not they're
not
what they're printing is access to pull
the slushy lever and when you do
when we go to clean the slushie machine
we have to empty it so we hold the thing
open and drain what's left of the
slushie and let it all pour out and
that's what feels like is happening
it's their emptying thing the great
reset this the economy and everything is
being stripped of resources very slowly
and then eventually it gets reset filled
with hot water and cleaning solution and
scrubbed out and then something else is
put inside you know i'm gonna go
with uh inflation or at least argue for
it a bit and one interesting thing is i
wrote the first draft of this book about
three years ago and i've been working on
it very slowly
and then with covid i thought now's the
time let me you know turbo through it
and get it done
and so i ended up going through the
parts that i'd already written i ended
up checking prices where i said you know
this rototillered amount on your tractor
is two thousand dollars
and i went back to tractor supply and
it's 2500 and you know this chicken
fencing is twelve dollars and i you know
go to lowes.com and it's 19
there has been a lot of inflation oh man
and i used to laugh
at these nut job conspiracists who were
saying they're stealth inflation it's
not showing up in the figures but
uh you know i don't know man i stumbled
into it myself i think it's real
all right let's do let's get a couple
more in as many as we can
all right let's see lone star carper
says tim i gave you a super chat maybe
your first when you played a trump video
game on this channel
great guest tonight love and enjoy the
show nightly oh there was a fighting
game that was made
in the i wonder if that would get you
banned at this point it was a it was a
fighting game where it was called like
andrew yang for president or something
and it was it was actually really fun
and really i was surprised at how
offensive it was because
elizabeth warren was wearing native
american gear and she would make
stereotypical like an offensive
you know sounds sounds and stuff and she
and her super move was to like summon a
giant bowl or something
and so it was really just like but i
guess was making fun of her for being
racist so it's okay whatever
and then you know donald trump throws
money as his special move or whatever it
was it was actually a really fun fun
game
yeah all right let's see oh
where are we at
chelsea nelson says my husband is a
composer arranger and is interested in
working with you he's emailed you a few
times
at jobs teamcast.com derricknelson.com
thanks i will
take a look we may have someone though
we may we may
we'll see jack of blades says play d
d with me you cowards what's a good way
to get in touch with you for your
podcast so i can introduce you to the
woke psychic brain
rat collective imprisoned by vice a la
planescape
um i suppose pitches at timkes.com yeah
so one of the shows we're going to do is
a weekly d
awesome series and we want to do a
campaign that's based around
like modern political ideas but
implemented through dnd
very cool and then just see how people
play and
how they try and resolve some of these
situations i'm playing a bunch of
neverwinter nights today to get
re-familiarized with 3.5
3.5 yeah the rule set dmd 3.5 one
writing project i want to do some day is
write a
uh rpg based on the aristilla science
fiction novels so
i've got infinite writing projects for
the next 10 or 20 years what's the era
still
uh the science fiction novels that i
wrote that i was talking about earlier
oh yeah dude
oh what's this firepower fantasy says
hey tim i mainly wanted a super chat to
support your content
but i also have to ask do any of y'all
have some recommended reading
you know i would recommend you check out
escape
the city oh uh uh and volumes one and
two
i was gonna say yeah travis is literally
his books
actually i'm really excited that you
have these you're gonna give us those
books right
absolutely dude because we we definitely
need them tim i will not only give you a
set of these books i will give you a set
of
wool socks from my sheep let me see this
these are literally from your sheep yeah
like you sheared it and yeah
literally i outsourced the knitting oh
you outsourced the name yeah
you ever see that uh that video of the
what they call them shrek
the sheep that yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it was just a massive
mass like wow they survive but you have
to share them right otherwise they go
so most sheep yes uh we have a more
primitive breed of sheep um and actually
uh there's pictures of them these are
icelandic sheep
and uh so you know these pictures are
from my farm uh i forget the name of
this sheep
and uh you know again this is you know
200 feet from my house and one of the
pastures uh where i keep sheep
um i just i don't even understand like
looking at this like how did this come
from a sheep
right right but i know it's where it
comes from yeah uh you know it starts
with uh my wife opening a star doll
stall door in the barn and me wrestling
the sheep out and uh
it ends about a year and a half later
and i'm wearing a set of uh wool socks
myself
you gotta like grab their legs like i
watch videos of people shearing sheep
and it's pretty intense like
tie your legs up or you don't have to
time up um you know there's this
wrestling thing that if somebody's feet
are off the ground
there's not much they can do so you
right you flip the sheep onto its butt
um
and yeah that's how we uh do the
shearing and they also get a bunch of
vitamins injected sort of you know
vitamin paste behind their teeth and
they swallow it and they get a shot
and there's a process we go through a
couple times a year i saw that thing
where there was like baby sheep on a
conveyor belt you'll see that they're
like sitting in a slide
i did not oh it was like they were
giving shots like vaccinations
and so it's like they're all just
sitting there with their feet up and
they slide forward and they fall in a
thing and then get dropped to the ground
they run away
uh things were a bit more earthy on our
farm i have a couple of times pulled a
baby lamb out of its mother and uh
that's exciting
once when there was a breech birth uh i
loaded a
pregnant uh uh you with a lamb half
coming out of her
uh into the car because we don't have a
truck right now drove her
the next town over to a vet so uh yeah
we need a conveyor belt that sounds
better
in terms of books though i'll shout out
to michael males book the anarchist
handbook
and michael malus is speechless which
they're always tricking michael knowles
michael knowles yeah the other michael
michael malice's anarchist handbook and
michael knowles
too many michaels and uh what are the
carol
small business looks incredible i still
not read that the war on small business
and jackpot's uh the answers
yeah yeah oh antifa book block yeah dot
com yeah yeah uh andy knows unmasked
and uh anybody else we need to shout out
i you know i i still haven't read the
creature from jekyll island i hear it's
phenomenal if you're interested in the
history of the federal reserve
cool all right we'll do a couple more
here we go
taylor ludke says third generation
almond grower tim take it easy on the
almonds are terrible for the environment
tweets
almond prices don't need to be beaten
down anymore do i have to cancel my tim
cast membership if this keeps up
i don't think i tweeted that i think i
said that almonds consume
tons of water and so the risk is when
california's in a big drought
or if this economic problems almonds are
on the chopping block
which is said i love almonds i like kind
bars i got almonds all up in oh so good
all right here we go deus flex says to
provide context for kyle kashuv
adult actress brandi love was kicked out
of a tpusa event by social conservatives
kyle not only approved but went on to
disavow libertarians
and called small government a fantasy
yes the uh this is hilarious that
there's actually a battle happening over
this and maybe
i think we'll maybe get maybe we'll get
into this in the bonus segment
i don't know if we need to but i am much
more libertarian i think the
conservatives are losing tons of allies
over this
i certainly understand what the
conservatives are saying i think i think
adult films
generally bad for people the way it's
kind of gone out of control
but at the same time small government
man
let people live and that live and you
got to build that coalition
and and support people when like find
out where you agree with people and you
need those allies in the great battle
yeah chrissy mayer
just did a podcast i believe with uh
brandy love today
right on well ladies and gentlemen if
you haven't already give that like
button a smash
subscribe to this channel share with
your friends you can follow us
at tim cast irl on facebook and
instagram at tim cast
underscore irl on tick tock help share
our videos and like them so we can
leverage those networks get more people
to go to timcast.com and become members
which is
the website is growing it's taken off we
got some bugs so apologies for that but
go to timcast.com
become a member for that members only
podcast new shows on the horizon you
guys got to check out
shane cashman's articles because he's
writing about um
you know mysteries and stuff but these
are legit like investigations into real
world phenomena
we're not talking about like some some
story where a guy claims he went and you
know his his apple pie was actually an
alien or something
like he writes a story about what's
happening with these birds that are
going missing
and so there's a bunch of stories about
crows falling from the sky
these are legitimate stories and then
he's you know you know asking
the experts talking to government
officials to figure out what's going on
and he did one that was really great
investigating a death
in west point that he knew about and it
looks like it might be a cover-up
so it's fun stuff it's fun stuff it's it
is more like spooky story-esque
but it is real stuff it's not it's not
fiction it's not
speculative i am no fan of people being
like i swear there was a ghost and i'll
prove it and it's like i care about
people who are skeptical but interested
in those mysteries
so check that stuff out there's a new
show coming on that soon we're going to
be working on the next couple of weeks
to have a full podcast
and you can follow me personally at
timcast now we just
shouted out a bunch of your books but
you want to mention your sci-fi books as
well uh
so my first time your social media too
yeah great uh first science fiction
novel was the powers of the earth
and it won the prometheus award in 2018
for best libertarian science fiction
novel
my second novel was causes of separation
the sequel to the first one
and it also won the prometheus award the
next year and i think this is the first
time that
an author won it two years in a row and
i think it's the first time that maybe
self-published books
won it and uh this is a saga uh
set about 50 years from now about small
government people and really kind of a
great divorce thing that we've been
talking about this whole time
uh you know there's this concept of
loyalty voice or exit where you disagree
with someone you either act loyal to
them and
swallow your objections or you speak up
in sort of a democratic way or you just
leave
my personal preference is just leaving
so this is a novel about that
involves lunar colonization it involves
artificial intelligence anti-gravity
uh genetically uplifted dogs and it's
all fairly hard science fiction it's not
uh you know
uh the force and lightsabers and stuff
fantasy stuff yeah
and um you know they've got something on
the order of 500 four and a half or five
star reviews so it's diesel stuff and if
you like science fiction please give it
a shot
yeah i i don't write small books um i
like big books and i kind of lie
uh well for some reason hbo uh you know
licenses for a tv
show just make sure you finish the books
before right
i think my opinions uh are such that i
never have a major media deal i i think
uh tim cast uh
is where i belong maybe we'll have to do
it yeah you know i was thinking of doing
is taking a room and making the entire
room a green screen
because then you can make movies about
anything or project green light on the
walls all around because then i think
that's harder
we could just paint a room green and put
lights on i'm so into this uh well ian
you have a website
i do it's ian crossland.net and i'm in
crossland travis thanks for coming man i
love talking about having me this is a
systemic
transfer or alterations that are
potential
yeah and pv equals nrt we'll talk about
that we're talking about inflation
and uh free energy yeah that's right
sounds good and you guys are more than
welcome to follow me
on twitter at sourpatchlids we will see
you all over at timcast.com in the
members podcast coming up around 11 or
so p.m thanks for hanging out we'll see
you then
you